Many adults may not know that simply being over 50 puts them at increased risk for shingles. Help prevent shingles in patients over 50 with shingricks. Shingricks is indicated for the prevention of herpes zoster, HZ, or shingles in adults 50 years of age or older. Consult the product monograph at gsk.ca slash shinricks slash PM for contra indications, warnings and precautions, adverse reactions, interactions, dosing and administration information. To request a product monograph or to report an adverse event, please call 1-800-387-7374.
许多成年人可能不知道，年过五十就会增加患上带状疱疹的风险。使用 Shingricks 帮助五十岁以上的患者预防带状疱疹。Shingricks 适用于预防五十岁及以上成人的带状疱疹（又称 HZ 或 shingles）。有关禁忌症、警告和注意事项、不良反应、相互作用以及剂量和给药信息，请查阅产品说明书，网址为 gsk.ca 斜杠 shinricks 斜杠 PM。如需索取产品说明书或报告不良事件，请致电 1-800-387-7374。
Learn more at thinkshinricks.ca Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Welcome to Mountain City, a friendly hometown. This message, written in bold white text on a bright red sign, greets travellers approaching the US town of Mountain City in the northeast corner of Tennessee.
了解更多信息，请访问 thinkshinricks.ca。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目简介。欢迎来到山城，一个友好的家乡。这条用醒目红底白字粗体书写的标语，迎接着从田纳西州东北角驶近美国山城镇的旅行者。
As the local population has never peaked beyond 2,600 people, Mountain City residents remain close-knit. They live a slow-paced lifestyle among the mountains, valleys and forests. The summers are warm, the winters are short, cold and wet, and it's partly cloudy all year round. There is no public transport, so everybody has a car, and that car is more often than not a pickup truck. Most residents own a gun. Many people own several.
由于当地人口从未超过 2,600 人，山城居民之间的关系非常紧密。他们在群山、山谷和森林间过着慢节奏的生活。这里的夏天温暖，冬天短暂、寒冷且潮湿，全年部分时间多云。这里没有公共交通，因此每个人都有一辆汽车，而且这辆车十有八九是皮卡。大多数居民都拥有一把枪，很多人甚至拥有好几把。
At around 6.30 on the morning of January 31, 2012, Brad Osborne was making his usual drive to pick up his friend and co-worker, Bill Payne. The two men worked at the Parkdale Mills textile plant and often carpooled to work. Bill was staying in his father's white single-story weatherboard house in Mountain City. He lived there with his partner, Billy Jean Hayworth, and their infant son, as well as Bill's father, Billy Ray Payne, better known around town as Poor Bill. When Brad Osborne arrived at the Payne house, Poor Bill had already left for work about an hour earlier.
2012 年 1 月 31 日早上 6 点半左右，布拉德·奥斯本（Brad Osborne）像往常一样开车去接他的朋友兼同事比尔·佩恩（Bill Payne）。这两个人在帕克代尔米尔斯（Parkdale Mills）纺织厂工作，经常拼车上班。比尔住在山城他父亲的一栋白色单层木板房里。他和伴侣比利·琼·海沃思（Billy Jean Hayworth）及他们的小儿子，还有比尔的父亲比利·雷·佩恩（Billy Ray Payne）一起住在那里，镇上的人们更习惯叫他“穷比尔”（Poor Bill）。当布拉德·奥斯本到达佩恩家时，“穷比尔”大约在一小时前就已经出门上班了。
Brad pulled into the driveway and remained in his car. Usually, Bill would emerge from the house when Brad arrived. They started work at 7am, but the drive to the factory wasn't far. The sun had yet to rise, and Brad could see a light emanating from Bill's bedroom window, though there was no movement within. Brad tutored the horn and waited, but Bill didn't appear. He tried calling Bill's cell phone, but was unable to get through. Minutes passed, and Brad became increasingly concerned about being late for work.
布拉德把车开进车道，坐在车里没动。通常情况下，布拉德一到，比尔就会从屋里出来。他们早上 7 点上班，但开车到工厂并不远。太阳还没升起，布拉德可以看到比尔的卧室窗户透出灯光，但里面没有任何动静。布拉德按了两下喇叭并等待着，但比尔没有出现。他尝试拨打比尔的手机，但打不通。几分钟过去了，布拉德越来越担心上班迟到。
He got out of his car and walked over to the house to hurry his friend along. Knowing that it was rarely locked, Brad headed to a sliding glass door at the rear of the house. When he's knocks when unanswered, Brad let himself in. An alarm clock was going off in one of the bedrooms. Brad picked up the landline in the living room and called Bill's cell again, but he couldn't hear it ring. Then, Brad heard something. It sounded like the quiet whimper of a baby. Not feeling comfortable with going into the bedrooms where Billy Jean and her baby might be
他下了车，走到屋前催促他的朋友快一点。布拉德知道门通常不上锁，便径直走向房子后方的推拉玻璃门。在敲门无人应答后，布拉德自己推门走了进去。其中一间卧室里正响着闹钟。布拉德拿起客厅里的座机再次拨打比尔的手机，但他听不到手机铃声。接着，布拉德听到了一些声音。听起来像是一个婴儿轻轻的呜咽声。布拉德觉得走进比利·琼和她孩子可能在睡觉的卧室不太妥当，
sleeping, Brad called out once more. He was met with silence and took this as his cue to leave. Brad drove alone to the textile plant, only to discover that Bill was not there, and did not turn up as the morning wore on. Later that morning at around 10, another visitor pulled up to the pain house. Roy Stevens arrived to pick up his mail, which had been sent to poor Bill's place. His wife, Linda, stayed in the car while Roy let himself in via the rear sliding glass door. Roy hollered out, sure that somebody must be home. After receiving no response, he ventured down the hallway towards the bedrooms.
于是他又大声喊了几句。迎接他的是一片寂静，他把这当作自己该离开的信号。布拉德独自开车去了纺织厂，结果发现比尔不在那儿，而且随着早晨过去也没有出现。当天上午 10 点左右，另一位访客将车停在了佩恩家门口。罗伊·斯蒂芬斯（Roy Stevens）来取寄到“穷比尔”住处的信件。他的妻子琳达留在车里，而罗伊则通过后方的推拉玻璃门自己走了进去。罗伊大声喊了几声，确信家里应该有人。在没有得到回应后，他顺着走廊朝卧室走去。
As he approached the first room, Roy saw what looked like blood near the doorway. Roy opened the door into the bedroom Bill shared with Billy Jean. He spotted a 36-year-old Bill face up on the bed. His face was badly beaten and blood coagulated around his neck. Roy rushed to Bill, grabbed his arms and shook him, hoping to get a response. When he got none, he raced outside, yelling for Linda. Linda was trained in CPR. She tried to find a pulse in Bill's neck before realizing that his throat had been cut. As his wife called 911, Roy heard something coming from another part of the house. He made his way down the hallway to a second bedroom. Inside, 23-year-old Billy
当他走近第一个房间时，罗伊看到门廊附近有类似血迹的东西。罗伊推开比尔和比利·琼共用的卧室的门。他发现 36岁的比尔面朝上躺在床上。他的脸被打得面目全非，脖子周围凝固着血液。罗伊冲向比尔，抓住他的胳膊并摇晃他，希望能得到回应。在没有得到任何反应后，他冲到屋外，大声呼喊琳达。琳达受过心肺复苏（CPR）培训。她试图在比尔的颈部寻找脉搏，却意识到他的喉咙已经被割断了。就在他的妻子拨打 911 时，罗伊听到屋里另一个地方传来声音。他顺着走廊走向第二间卧室。里面，23 岁的比利·琼·海沃思
Jean Hayworth was lying in a pool of blood on the floor of her son's nursery. Tight in her arms was her baby boy. He didn't stir. His face was blotchy and red and blood caked his sleeper suit and the back of his head. It was clear Billy Jean was deceased. To Roy's relief, her baby was still breathing. All of the blood around him belonged to his mother. The baby himself was unhurt. Linda broke down as she described the condition of the little boy to the 911 operator. Quote, The baby kind of to me as a parent looks like maybe it's been crying for a while and probably cried till he can't cry no more. Both Bill and Billy Jean had been shot in the head. There were also deep slash wounds across Bill's neck, although it was unclear
正躺在她儿子婴儿房地板的一滩血泊中。她紧紧怀抱着自己的小男孩。他一动不动。他的脸红一块白一块，血迹沾满了他的连体睡衣和后脑勺。显然，比利·琼已经死亡。令罗伊宽慰的是，她的宝宝还在呼吸。他身边的所有鲜血都属于他的母亲。婴儿本身没有受伤。琳达在向 911 接线员描述小男孩的情况时情绪崩溃了。原话是：“作为一名家长，在我看来这个宝宝好像已经哭了很久，可能哭到再也哭不出来为止。”比尔和比利·琼的头部都中了枪。比尔的脖子上也有深深的刀伤，尽管目前尚不清楚
whether they were sustained pre or post mortem. Neither victim had defensive wounds, suggesting they had been taken by surprise. With Bill in his underwear and Billy Jean in pajamas, it appeared as though the couple had been confronted while they were still in bed or shortly after waking. Everything was normal when poor Bill left for work at around 5.30. The pair were presumably dead by the time Brad Osborne had arrived to pick up Bill an hour later. Tennessee Bureau of Investigation Agent Scott Lott arrived on the scene. There were several firearms at the residence, but the shotguns and a .22 caliber pistol he located were not the murder weapons. The bullets fired upon the victims had come from a .38 caliber or 9 millimeter handgun.
这些伤是在死前还是死后造成的。两位受害者都没有防御性伤口，这表明他们是在毫无防备的情况下遭到袭击的。比尔穿着内衣，比利·琼穿着睡衣，看起来这对夫妇是在还躺在床上或刚醒来不久时遭到对质的。“穷比尔”在 5 点半左右出门上班时一切正常。推测当布拉德·奥斯本一小时后到达接比尔时，两人已经遇害。田纳西州调查局（Tennessee Bureau of Investigation）特工斯科特·洛特（Scott Lott）抵达现场。住所里有几支枪械，但他找到的猎枪和一把 .22 口径手枪并不是凶器。向受害者开枪的子弹来自 .38 口径或 9 毫米手枪。
Murder suicide was swiftly ruled out. The gun and knife used in the crime were missing. Nothing was found at the house that hinted at the perpetrator's identity. Neighbors described Bill Payne and Billy Jean Hayworth as a nice young couple. They didn't hear anything suspicious the morning of the murders. Usually, poor Bill's dog would bark if strangers came to the house, which made the investigators wonder, was the killer someone known to the family, perhaps even welcomed inside. A search of the Payne residence uncovered a small quantity of drugs, including methamphetamine.
谋杀后自杀的可能性很快被排除。犯罪中使用的枪支和刀具不见了。在屋里没有找到任何暗示凶手身份的线索。邻居们将比尔·佩恩和比利·琼·海沃思描述为一对很好的一对年轻夫妇。他们在谋杀案发生的早晨没有听到任何可疑的声音。通常情况下，如果有陌生人来到家里，“穷比尔”的狗会叫，这让调查人员不禁怀疑，凶手是这家人认识的人，甚至可能是被迎进门的人。对佩恩住所的搜查发现了一小批毒品，其中包括甲基苯丙胺（冰毒）。
Police also recovered a meth pipe and some prescription medication. Mountain City was going through a drug crisis at the time, but nobody in the Payne household was on the police radar as being part of any large-scale dealing. Billy Jean's best friend, a woman named Lindsay Thomas, had been at the Payne home the day before the murders. Billy Jean mentioned receiving a fresh batch of pills for her and Bill to sell. The couple apparently carried out some low-level drug dealing to make extra cash to buy things for their baby. Lindsay wondered if a buyer was supposed to meet Bill before he left for work, and things turned deadly. This seemed even more likely given that methamphetamine was not found
警方还搜获了一个吸冰毒的烟斗和一些处方药。山城当时正经历一场毒品危机，但佩恩家里的任何人都不在警方的雷达上，不被认为参与了任何大规模贩毒活动。比利·琼的闺蜜琳德丝·托马斯（Lindsay Thomas）在谋杀案发生的前一天去过佩恩家。比利·琼提到收到了一批新药丸，供她和比尔售卖。这对夫妇显然进行了一些低层级的毒品交易，以赚取外快来给他们的孩子买东西。琳德丝想知道是否有一个买家原本要在比尔上班前与他见面，结果事情演变成了致命惨剧。考虑到受害者体内并没有检测出甲基苯丙胺，
in either of the victim's systems, but was sitting out on a plate with a straw beside it, as though someone had recently taken a hit. Bill's cell phone records showed the numbers of those who had called him prior to his death. They led to two of his friends, who admitted that they occasionally bought pills from him. It was no major drug operation, however. Bill sometimes sold or swapped his prescription medication with a small group of contacts. His friends had intended to pick some up the night before he was killed, but Bill had sent them a text at 11.30 saying that he was tired and was not going to meet them. The double homicide was the biggest incident Johnson County had seen in a very long time.
反而有一盘药丸放在盘子里，旁边还放着一根吸管，就像是有人刚刚吸食过一样，这种可能性似乎更高了。比尔的手机通话记录显示了他在死前打过电话的号码。这些号码指向他的两个朋友，他们承认偶尔会从他那里买药丸。然而，这并不是什么大的贩毒团伙。比尔有时会与一小群联系人出售或交换他的处方药。他的朋友们本打算在他被杀的前一天晚上去取一些药，但比尔在 11 点半给他们发了一条短信，说他累了，不打算和他们见面了。这起双重谋杀案是强生县（Johnson County）很久以来发生的最大事件。
Everybody in Mountain City knew the couple or members of their families. Theories are bound, especially online on local forums. Members of Billie Jean's family fronted the media and begged her killer to come forward. Her mother questioned how anyone could leave her infant grandson an orphan. She explained how much Billie Jean and Bill loved being parents, adding, I didn't know a soul that didn't like them. Jamie Curd lived in a trailer at the end of a muddy driveway up a steep hill. With its outdoor laundry tub and sofa on the porch, it was a typical dwelling of those who were doing it toughest in Johnson County.
山城的每个人都认识这对夫妇或他们家族的成员。各种猜测甚嚣尘上，尤其是在当地论坛的网上。比利·琼家族的成员出面面对媒体，恳求凶手自首。她的母亲质问怎么会有人忍心让她的外孙变成孤儿。她解释说比利·琼和比尔有多么热爱为人父母，并补充道：“我认识的人里没有一个不喜欢他们的。”杰米·库尔德（Jamie Curd）住在一条陡峭山坡上泥泞车道尽头的一辆拖车里。这里有户外洗衣盆和门廊上的沙发，是强生县生活最艰难的人的典型住所。
Jamie had dropped out of school to work at the Parkdale Mills Textile Plant, where he labored through 12-hour shifts. But he was able to work alongside his cousin Bill Payne. The two were close despite their differences. Bill was popular and charismatic with lots of interests and hobbies. He was a coin collector who enjoyed NASCAR, trips to Las Vegas, and had a reputation as a bit of a player. He embraced life and had a tendency to blow his paycheck as soon as he got it. Jamie, on the other hand, was the sort of person that people didn't notice much. If they did, they thought him pleasant, harmless, and quiet. A follower, not a leader. At 35 years old, he had never had a proper girlfriend. He also had a stammer,
杰米辍学后在帕克代尔米尔斯纺织厂工作，在那里经历着 12 小时连轴转的劳累班次。但他能够和他的表弟比尔·佩恩一起工作。尽管两人存在差异，但关系很亲密。比尔很受欢迎，极具个人魅力，有着很多兴趣和爱好。他是一个硬币收藏爱好者，喜欢纳斯卡赛车（NASCAR）、去拉斯维加斯旅行，并且有着花花公子的名声。他热爱生活，往往一拿到工资就挥霍一空。相比之下，杰米则是那种不太引人注目的人。如果人们注意到他，也会觉得他随和、无害、安静。是个随从，而不是领袖。35 岁的他从未谈过真正的恋爱。他还有结巴，
as well as a condition that meant he needed to wear dark glasses all the time, even inside. In late 2009, Billie Jean Hayworth was hired at the textile plant where Jamie Curd and Bill Payne worked. The two Billys clicked immediately. They had many shared interests, both being outdoorsy types who enjoyed fishing, hiking, camping, and running. They also liked to visit flea markets, yard sales, and auctions. Bill spoke of falling head over heels in love. When Billie Jean discovered she was pregnant, Bill was overjoyed. The future for the soon-to-be parents looked bright. Bill had had his share of run-ins with the law but cleaned himself up after meeting Billie Jean. He drank less, quit partying, and had eyes only for her. He enrolled in a clinic
以及一种需要他一直戴着墨镜的疾病，即使在室内也是如此。2009 年底，比利·琼·海沃思被杰米·库尔德和比尔·佩恩工作的纺织厂录用。两个“比利”一拍即合。他们有很多共同的兴趣，都是喜欢钓鱼、徒步旅行、露营和跑步的户外运动爱好者。他们还喜欢逛跳蚤市场、庭院旧货出售和拍卖会。比尔曾说自己深深地坠入爱河。当比利·琼发现自己怀孕时，比尔欣喜若狂。这对准父母的未来看起来一片光明。比尔过去也曾有过触犯法律的时候，但在遇到比利·琼后他洗心革面了。他喝得少了，戒掉了派对，眼里只有她。他去诊所登记，
to kick his drug dependence, and to the surprise of those who knew him even gave up smoking. Yet, not everyone seemed happy for the young couple. Not long after they went public with their pregnancy, anonymous, nasty comments about the pair appeared online. Even Billie Jean's closest two friends, Lindsay Thomas and Tara Osbourne, were not immune to the criticism. It started with someone calling himself Matt Potter. Matt vilified the three women on the Mountain City Topics Forum, a community news site that was incredibly popular in town. Someone named Kelly weighed in and supported Matt's accusations, as did another user going by the name Dan White. Together, they accused the women of promiscuity, spreading sexually transmitted diseases,
戒掉了毒瘾，而且在认识他的人的惊讶中，甚至戒了烟。然而，似乎并非所有人都为这对年轻夫妇感到高兴。就在他们公开怀孕消息后不久网上就出现了关于两人的匿名恶毒评论。甚至比利·琼最亲密的两个朋友琳德丝·托马斯和塔拉·奥斯本（Tara Osbourne）也未能幸免于这些批评。这一切始于一个自称马特·波特（Matt Potter）的人。马特在山城话题论坛（Mountain City Topics Forum）上诋毁这三个女人，这是一个在镇上非常受欢迎的社区新闻网站。一个名叫凯利（Kelly）的人加入进来并支持马特的指责，另一个化名丹·白（Dan White）的用户也是如此。他们一起指责这些女性行为不端、传播性传播疾病、
drug-taking, and a litany of other transgressions while calling them vile names. Others chimed in, too. The posts were vicious and disturbing. One comment directed at Billie Jean ended, Fuck them. I hope they die, die, die. And that baby. And Bill. In the aftermath of Bill and Billie Jean's murders, several townsfolk name dropped to Jamie Curd to investigators. According to reports, he recently had a falling out with his cousin. Jamie explained that this was because Bill had been ranting at him about something posted online. Jamie said he wasn't on social media, so he didn't know anything about it. He also denied knowing anything about the murders. Yet, the investigation kept circling back to Jamie,
吸毒以及犯下一系列其他过错，同时用恶劣的词汇称呼她们。其他人也随声附和。这些帖子恶毒且令人不安。一条针对比利·琼的评论以这句话结尾：“去他们的。我希望他们去死、去死、去死。还有那个婴儿。还有比尔。”在比尔和比利·琼被谋杀后，几个镇民向调查人员提到了杰米·库尔德。据报道，他最近和他的表弟闹翻了。杰米解释说，这是因为比尔一直在对他大声抱怨网上发布的一些东西。杰米说他不上社交媒体，所以对此一无所知。他还否认知道关于谋杀案的任何事情。然而，调查一直围绕着杰米打转，
and he agreed to take a polygraph test. Although such tests are unreliable and inadmissible in court, police find them useful in interrogations to discover how people act when lying. The test told them that Jamie was not being honest, particularly when asked if he knew who killed Bill and Billie Jean. The interrogator told Jamie his polygraph results and assured him, We're not looking to crucify anybody. We just want the truth. We're looking for who pulled the trigger, that's all. Are you the type of man who could shoot a woman, probably begging for her life, while her baby is in her arms? Jamie responded, No.
他同意接受测谎仪测试。尽管此类测谎仪不可靠且在法庭上不被采纳，但警方发现它们在审讯中很有用，可以用来发现人们在说谎时的行为表现。测试结果告诉他们杰米没有说实话，特别是当被问及他是否知道是谁杀害了比尔和比利·琼时。审讯员将测谎结果告诉杰米并向他保证：“我们不是想把谁钉上十字架。我们只是想要真相。我们只想找出是谁扣动了扳机，仅此而已。你是那种会枪杀一个可能在乞求活命、而她怀里还抱着孩子的女性的男人吗？”杰米回答：“不是。”
Appealing to Jamie's better nature, the interrogator told him how good he'd feel if he told the truth. After about an hour and a half, sensing that Jamie was beginning to crack, the interrogator pressed him. Who shot him? Who had the gun? Jamie responded, He did. They kept pushing. He who? Stickers covering the back windshield of Buddy Potter's truck made it clear that he staunchly supported the Second Amendment as well as the National Rifle Association. He owned many guns, two of which he carried at all times, one in a shoulder harness and one on his ankle. Sometimes he wore a holster around his hips, Old West, a gunslinger style. Buddy was the nickname of local man Marvin Potter Jr. Seven years earlier in 2004,
为了唤醒杰米的善意，审讯员告诉他如果说出真相他会有多轻松。大约一个半小时后，感觉到杰米开始崩溃，审讯员逼问道：“是谁开的枪？谁有枪？”杰米回答：“是他。”他们继续逼问：“他是谁？”巴迪·波特（Buddy Potter）卡车后挡风玻璃上的贴纸表明，他坚定地支持宪法第二修正案以及全国步枪协会。他拥有许多枪支，其中两支他随身携带，一支放在肩带里，一支绑在脚踝上。有时他会在臀部佩戴枪套，那是美国旧西部枪手风格。巴迪是当地人马文·波特二世（Marvin Potter Jr.）的绰号。七年前的 2004 年，
the Potter family, consisting of Marvin, his wife Barbara, and their adult daughter Janelle, moved from Pennsylvania to Mountain City. Like many small towns, most of the locals had lived there for generations and could be slow to warm to outsiders. It didn't help that the Potter family kept to themselves and quickly developed a reputation of being odd. Buddy Potter told anyone who'd listen about his military history, including his experiences fighting in the Vietnam War. He spoke of being confined in a prisoner of war camp and rescuing fellow injured Marines. For this, he was awarded the Navy Cross Medal, the second highest military award for valor. He added it to his three silver stars,
波特一家，由马文、他的妻子芭芭拉（Barbara）以及他们的成年女儿珍妮尔（Janelle）组成，从宾夕法尼亚州搬到了山城。和许多小镇一样，大多数当地人已经在那里生活了好几代，对局外人可能会比较冷淡。波特一家独来独往，很快便落得个古怪的名声，这并没有帮到他们什么忙。巴迪·波特向任何愿意听的人讲述他的军旅生涯，包括他在越南战争中战斗的经历。他谈到自己曾被关押在战俘营中，并营救过受伤的陆战队战友。为此，他被授予了海军十字勋章，这是表彰英勇行为的第二高军事勋章。他把它与他的三枚银星勋章、
bronze star medal, purple heart medal, airborne wings, and scuba badge. He proudly displayed photographs of himself in uniform with all his decorations. After attending jump, diving, survival, and recon schools, he said he was assigned to Marine Force Reconnaissance, a special operations force tasked with military intelligence missions. He then worked with the Central Intelligence Agency, which handled national security. Everything that happened there was classified. He couldn't and wouldn't talk about it to anybody. Jamie Curd became known to Buddy when the Potter family computer started having issues. Jamie had a reputation as a computer tinkerer who could fix basic tech issues
铜星勋章、紫心勋章、伞兵翼章和潜水徽章摆放在一起。他自豪地展示自己穿着带有所有勋章制服的照片。在参加了跳伞、潜水、生存和侦察学校后，他说他被分派到海军陆战队武力侦察排，这是一支承担军事情报任务的特种作战部队。随后他与负责国家安全的中央情报局（CIA）合作。那里发生的一切都是机密。他不能也不会对任何人谈及此事。当波特一家的电脑开始出现问题时，杰米·库尔德走入了巴迪的视野。杰米以精通电脑而闻名，能够解决基础的技术问题，
and was quick to offer the Potters his assistance. Upon arriving at their house, he was taken to the troublesome device. It was located in a common area of the home where it was primarily used by everyone but Buddy, who seemed to have no interest in it. Jamie returned to the Potter house several times to clean up and reformat their hard drive. Buddy and Barbara Potter accepted his help and tolerated him being around, despite not liking him that much. One day, Barbara Potter noticed her daughter in possession of a prepaid cell phone she had never seen before. While examining it, Barbara discovered it contained messages from Jamie Curd.
并且很乐意向波特一家提供帮助。一到他们家，他便被带到了那台出问题的设备前。它位于家里的一个公共区域，除了巴迪之外，其他人主要都在使用它，巴迪似乎对它毫无兴趣。杰米几次返回波特家清理并重新格式化他们的硬盘。尽管并不那么喜欢杰米，巴迪和芭芭拉·波特还是接受了他的帮助，并容忍他在附近出没。一天，芭芭拉·波特注意到她的女儿拥有一个她从未见过的预付费手机。在检查时，芭芭拉发现里面有来自杰米·库尔德的信息。
He had supplied it to Janelle so they could speak in private. With an IQ of 72, 27-year-old Janelle functioned at around a fourth grade level. Her entire school life was spent in special education and by the time she graduated, Janelle didn't have the skills to get or hold onto a job or drive a car. With a slew of health problems, including type 1 diabetes and partial deafness, she was put onto a social security disability payment and lived with her parents, who took care of all her needs. As such, both Buddy and Barbara were highly protective of Janelle and were displeased that Jamie, with his drinking and drug-taking habits,
他把手机提供给珍妮尔，以便他们能私下交谈。27 岁的珍妮尔智商为 72，智力水平大约在小学四年级左右。她的整个学校生活都是在特殊教育中度过的，到毕业时，珍妮尔甚至没有能力找到并保住一份工作或驾驶汽车。由于患有一系列健康问题，包括 1 型糖尿病和部分失明，她被安排领取社会安全残疾津贴，并与照顾她所有需求的父母住在一起。因此，巴迪和芭芭拉对珍妮尔极力保护，并且对杰米酗酒和吸毒的习惯感到不满，
was showing interest in their naive and vulnerable daughter. Upon realizing that Jamie Curd had been covertly pursuing her daughter, Barbara Potter texted that she was onto him and confiscated the phone he had given Janelle. She had no idea that Jamie supplied Janelle with another. Then in February 2010, the police called the Potters after finding Janelle wandering the dark streets alone. She was under the impression that she was going to a lope with the Jamie that night, which was his birthday. Jamie, however, had spent the evening drinking and had passed out. The next morning, Buddy Potter called Jamie and thundered down the line for him to stay away
因为他表现出对他们天真且脆弱的女儿的兴趣。在意识到杰米·库尔德一直在暗中追求他们的女儿后，芭芭拉·波特发短信说她已经看穿了他，并没收了他给珍妮尔的手机。她不知道杰米又给了珍妮尔一部。接着在 2010 年 2 月，警方在发现珍妮尔独自一人在黑暗的街道上游荡后给波特家打了电话。她当时以为自己那天晚上要和杰米私奔，而那天正是杰米的生日。然而，杰米却花了一晚上喝酒，喝得不省人事。第二天早上，巴迪·波特打电话给杰米，在电话那头大发雷霆，让他离他女儿远点。
from his daughter. When he was interrogated in relation to the murders of Bill Payne and Billie Jean Hayworth, Jamie implicated Buddy Potter. He then asked a bizarre question, is the CIA here? When asked for the meaning behind his strange query, Jamie explained that was because Buddy Potter had told him he was with the CIA. He remarked, I was hoping the CIA had my back. Jamie told investigators he participated in the murders because he was afraid of Buddy. He never wanted to kill anyone and hadn't done anything violent before. He said he felt horrible. Bill was like a brother to him. Agent Lott asked Jamie to call Buddy and ask what happened to the
在被审讯有关比尔·佩恩和比利·琼·海沃思的谋杀案时，杰米供出了巴迪·波特。接着他问了一个奇怪的问题：“中情局（CIA）在这里吗？”当被要求解释他这个奇怪提问背后的含义时，杰米解释说那是因为巴迪·波特曾告诉他自己曾效力于中情局。他评论道：“我当时希望中情局能做我的后盾。”杰米告诉调查人员，他参与谋杀是因为他害怕巴迪。他从来不想杀任何人，以前也没有做过任何暴力的事情。他说他感觉糟透了。比尔对他的感觉就像兄弟一样。洛特特工要求杰米打电话给巴迪，询问谋杀案中使用的
gun and knife used in the murders. Barbara Potter answered the phone and spoke with Jamie for a few minutes. She was aware that Jamie had been arrested and asked if he had taken a lie detector test and whether he had passed it. He said yes to both questions. When Buddy came to the phone, Jamie muttered, well, they're pointing fingers. Buddy responded, oh, Jiminy Christmas. Buddy told Jamie there was no reason for anyone to suspect him because the homicides looked like a drug deal gone bad. As instructed by the cops, Jamie asked, you got rid of everything that was from Bill's, right? Uh-huh, Buddy responded. It wasn't quite a confession, but it was enough. Police descended on the Potter residence and
枪支和刀具去了哪里。芭芭拉·波特接了电话，和杰米交谈了几分钟。她知道杰米被捕了，并询问他是否接受过测谎仪测试以及是否通过了。他对这两个问题都回答了“是”。当巴迪来接电话时，杰米喃喃道：“嗯，他们在把矛头指向我。”巴迪回答：“哦，天哪（Jiminy Christmas）。”巴迪告诉杰米，没有人有理由怀疑他，因为这起凶杀案看起来像是一起搞砸了的毒品交易。按照警察的指示，杰米问：“你把所有属于比尔的东西都处理掉了，对吧？”“嗯，”巴迪回答。这虽然算不上是一份供词，但也足够了。警察突袭了波特住所并
arrested Buddy, who was armed even at 3.30am. Officers then moved through the house searching for evidence. At one stage, Barbara Potter, who had been sitting on a couch in the living room beside her daughter, reached over, picked up a stack of papers and ripped them in half. All this did was bring attention to the documents. Barbara was ordered to hand them over. They consisted of printed email correspondence and included candid photos of Billie Jean Hayworth and her best friend, Lindsay Thomas. The images had been taken from the women's social media pages. The emails had subject lines like Billie Haw for Billie Jean and Panface for Lindsay. This wasn't the only interesting paper detectives found. In the back of Buddy's truck were three
逮捕了巴迪，甚至在凌晨 3 点半时他身上还带着武器。随后，警官们在屋内搜寻证据。有一个阶段，一直坐在客厅沙发上女儿身边的芭芭拉·波特伸手拿起一叠纸，把它们撕成了两半。她这么做反而让这些文件受到了关注。芭芭拉被命令交出它们。这些文件由打印出来的电子邮件通信组成，其中包含比利·琼·海沃思和她闺蜜琳德丝·托马斯的抓拍照片。这些图片取自这些女性的社交媒体页面。这些电子邮件的主题行诸如“比利·霍用于比利·琼”（Billie Haw for Billie Jean）以及“平脸用于琳德丝”（Panface for Lindsay）。这并不是侦探们发现的唯一有趣的文件。在巴迪的卡车后面有三个
large garbage bags full of shredded paper, bundled up, ready to be disposed of. Officers seized the Potter's computer, an external hard drive, and a green spiral notebook next to the monitor. They also took what detectives would later call an arsenal. 32 firearms, including rifles, semi-automatics, handguns, an AK-47, and shotguns, along with a huge supply of ammunition. The gun used against Bill Payne and Billie Jean Hayworth was not among them. Buddy Potter was led into the same interrogation room Jamie Curd had sat in earlier. He was asked, you know why you're here, right? Buddy responded,
装满碎纸的大垃圾袋，被捆绑在一起，准备丢弃。警官们查封了波特的电脑、一个外置硬盘以及显示器旁的一个绿色螺旋笔记本。他们还拿走了侦探们后来称之为军火库的东西。32 支枪械，包括步枪、半自动武器、手枪、AK-47 和猎枪，以及大量的弹药。用来对付比尔·佩恩和比利·琼·海沃思的枪并不在其中。巴迪·波特被带进杰米·库尔德之前坐过的那间审讯室。有人问他：“你知道你为什么来这里，对吧？”巴迪回答：
someone's told you that I'm the one that killed somebody. The Potter's had made a big impression on Mountain City in the short amount of time they had resided there. When inquiries were underway into the murders of Bill Payne and Billie Jean Hayworth, the Potter name kept cropping up, enough to put the family on Agent Lott's priority list. He paid them a visit. When Agent Lott told the Potters that he was investigating a double homicide, Buddy responded, everybody always points the finger at us for something. It was no secret that the Potter family had severe grievances with other townsfolk, Bill Payne and Billie Jean Hayworth especially. Their conflict had arisen from an online dispute
“有人告诉你我是杀害某人的那个人。”波特一家在山城居住的短短时间内留下了深刻的印象。在对比尔·佩恩和比利·琼·海沃思谋杀案展开调查时，“波特”这个名字不断浮现，足以让这一家人列入洛特特工的优先名单。他拜访了他们。当洛特特工告诉波特一家他正在调查一起双重谋杀案时，巴迪回答：“每个人总是为某些事情把矛头指向我们。”众所周知，波特一家与包括比尔·佩恩和比利·琼·海沃思在内的其他镇民有着严重的怨恨。他们的冲突源于一场在线争端，
that had turned intensely vitriolic. Buddy admitted to visiting the Payne House many times in relation to the feud, though denied involvement in the murders. Agent Lott asked if the Potters knew of anybody who would want to hurt the victims. They didn't, but Janelle spoke of a party at the Payne House that had made her uncomfortable. There had been drinking and drug use. Weapons, including an AK-47, were present. As she didn't want to involve herself in that lifestyle, Janelle didn't attend any more parties. She quickly fell out with the two billies and their circle of friends. Typical of the town, news of the broken friendship became a hot topic online, particularly on topics
这场争端已经变得极具恶意。巴迪承认因这场争端多次去过佩恩家，但否认参与谋杀。洛特特工询问波特一家是否知道有谁想要伤害受害者。他们不知道，但珍妮尔提到佩恩家曾举行过一次让她感到不舒服的聚会。那里有人喝酒和吸毒。现场有包括 AK-47 在内的武器。由于她不想卷入那种生活方式，珍妮尔没有再去参加任何聚会。她很快与两个“比利”以及他们的朋友圈闹翻了。正如这个小镇的典型情况一样，友谊破裂的消息成了网上的热门话题，特别是在那些话题讨论中，用户们尽管没有卷入这场争端却依然纷纷站队。一些人替珍妮尔辩护，指出她甜美的个性和单纯的心态。他们命令其他女人离她远点。另一些人则支持比尔、比利·琼以及他们的朋友。网上的口水战，
where users took sides despite having no involvement in the dispute. Some defended Janelle, noting her sweet nature and innocent mindset. They ordered the other women to leave her alone. Others stood by Bill and Billie Jean and their friends. The online bickering, mostly fueled by random community members or anonymous posters, only served to increase hostilities between the ex-friends. Janelle's social media accounts were hacked and fake pages had been created using her photo. Her father had to deal with baseless accusations of being a drug dealer. Efforts to quash the animosity were futile against the aggressive, cruel and degrading comments shared online. The Potter family accused Billie Jean Hayworth and her friends of instigating, continuing and
主要由随机的社区成员或匿名发帖者推波助澜，只会加剧前友人们之间的敌意。珍妮尔的社交媒体账户被黑客入侵，并冒用她的照片创建了虚假页面。她的父亲不得不应对他是毒贩的无端指责。面对网上那些充满攻击性、残酷且贬损的评论，试图平息敌意的努力显得徒劳无功。波特一家指责比利·琼·海沃思和她的朋友们挑起、持续并放大了骚扰，但也觉得比尔·佩恩也是一个推动因素。珍妮尔解释说，比尔总是试图去触碰别人的底线，任何与这对夫妇接触过的人都和他们有过节。芭芭拉·波特告诉洛特特工，有人把糖倒进了波特家的油箱里，巴迪的卡车被划伤了，他们的车库门被砸坏了，还有人朝他们的房子和珍妮尔的卧室窗户扔石头。尽管他们与受害者之间存在种种问题，
amplifying the harassment, but felt Bill Payne was also a driving factor. Janelle explained that Bill was always trying to push someone's buttons and that anyone who came into contact with the couple had trouble with them. Barbara Potter informed Agent Lott that sugar had been poured into the Potter's gas tanks, that Buddy's truck was scratched, their garage door was broken and rocks were thrown at their house and Janelle's bedroom window. Despite all the issues they had with the victims, Buddy assured Agent Lott that he would never wish murder upon anybody. Following Buddy Potter's arrest, he was asked whether he was a cold-hearted killer or his family's protector. Buddy responded, I'm a protector of my family to start with, but I did not do this.
但巴迪向洛特特工保证，他绝不会希望任何人被谋杀。在巴迪·波特被捕后，有人问他是一个冷酷无情的杀手还是他家人的保护者。巴迪回答：“首先我是我家人的保护者，但我没有做这件事。”有人告诉他，杰米·库尔德已经将他牵连进谋杀案中，对此巴迪回应道：“他在把我当替罪羊（甩锅给我）。”随着时间一小时小时过去，巴迪情绪失控了。他透露了自从他们与比尔和比利·琼发生矛盾以来，他的家人所遭受的骚扰程度。他说他的每个家庭成员都悬赏 3,000 美元，并补充道：“自从所有这些破事开始以来，我的生命受到过威胁，我的妻子受到过威胁，他们威胁要带走珍妮尔、砍掉她的头、在洗手间抓住她并谋杀她、因为她是处女而强奸她，还有太多废话了。”巴迪崩溃并抽泣起来。
He was told that Jamie Curd had already implicated him in the murders, to which Buddy replied, he's throwing me under the bus. As the hours wore on, Buddy became emotional. He revealed the extent of the harassment his family had received since their issues arose with Bill and Billie Jean. He said there was a $3,000 bounty on each member of his family, adding, Ever since all this crap started, I've had my life threatened, my wife has been threatened, they've threatened to take Janelle, cut her head off, catch her in a restroom and murder her, rape her because she's a virgin, and just so much bullshit. Buddy broke down and started sobbing.
随后有人问他：“珍妮尔和芭芭拉知道你做了什么吗？”他坚定地回答“不知道”。审讯结束后，巴迪打电话给他的妻子。他们的对话被秘密录音。巴迪开场说道：“芭芭拉，在你从别人那里发现之前，我想让你知道，我参与其中了。我做了。我不想让你再害怕了。”芭芭拉听起来并没有感到震惊，而是平静地回答说他不可能犯下谋杀罪，因为他一直和她在家。巴迪告诉芭芭拉：“我爱你，我这么做是为了保护你。”但芭芭拉并不买账。她说：“你没有罪，因为你一直在这里，
He was then asked, do Janelle and Barbara know what you did? He responded with a firm no. After the interview, Buddy called his wife. Their conversation was covertly recorded. Buddy opened with, Barbara, before you find out from somebody else, I want you to know, I was involved in it. I did it. I didn't want you to be afraid no more. Rather than sound shocked, Barbara responded calmly that he could not have committed the murders because he was at home with her the whole time. Buddy told Barbara, I love you, I did it to protect you. But Barbara wasn't having it. She said, you're not guilty because you were here,
你必须这么说，你一直在这里，我看见你了。你一直没有休息，你也没有吸氧，你现在不是平时的自己了。”在结束通话前，芭芭拉重复道：“别担心，亲爱的，你就在这里，我亲眼看见你就在这里。”侦探们感到迷惑不解。这究竟是一个深爱丈夫、试图为丈夫提供不在场证明的妻子？还是巴迪·波特本就无辜？芭芭拉·波特后来批评警方对巴迪进行了长达数小时的审讯，却不允许他获得正常运转所需的氧气。她指责警方逼供，因为当被剥夺氧气时，
you have to say that, you were here, I saw you. You haven't had no rest and you don't have your oxygen, you're not yourself right now. Before concluding the call, Barbara repeated, don't worry honey, you were right here, I saw you right here. Detectives were mystified. Was this a loving wife trying to provide an alibi for her husband? Or was Buddy Potter innocent? Barbara Potter would later criticise the police for interviewing Buddy for hours without allowing him access to the oxygen that he needed to function properly. She accused them of coercing a confession because when denied oxygen,
她的丈夫经常会说一些奇怪且不真实的话。一位医生后来表示，虽然巴迪的低氧血症病史可能会导致精神状态受损，但并没有已知的低氧血症会导致患者说谎的案例。巴迪·波特和杰米·库尔德都被控一级谋杀，保释金各定为 150 万美元，两人均未交保释放。随后，当杰米突然翻供时，调查工作遭受了沉重打击。无论如何，侦探们仍然确信杰米和巴迪实施了谋杀，并迅速着手收集证据来证明这一点。
her husband often said strange and untrue things. A doctor later stated that while Buddy's history of hypoxia could have contributed to an impaired state of mind, there were no known cases of hypoxia causing a patient to lie. Both Buddy Potter and Jamie Curd were charged with first degree murder, with bonds set at $1.5 million each, neither made bail. The investigation then took a massive hit when Jamie suddenly recanted his confession. Regardless, detectives remained certain that Jamie and Buddy carried out the murders, and worked quickly on gathering evidence to prove it.
一名特工的任务是从巴迪卡车里发现的垃圾袋中，一片一片地拼凑起那些碎纸。这是一个极其缓慢的过程，但人们相信这些纸条握有能破解此案的关键。这位特工完成了惊人的工作。她成功重建了大约 100 页文件。事实证明，这些文件既具有启发性又令人困惑。其中许多是芭芭拉·波特和一个名叫克里斯（Chris）的神秘男子之间的网上通信打印件。这些消息的日期从 2011 年到 2012 年。芭芭拉称克里斯为“儿子”，并在给他的信息署名为“妈妈”。反过来，他以“爱你们所有人，你们的儿子克里斯”结束信件。
One agent was tasked with piecing together the paper in the garbage bags found in Buddy's truck, shred by shred. It was a painstaking slow process, but it was believed that they held a key that would break open the case. The agent did an astonishing job. She managed to reconstruct around 100 pages. They proved to be both enlightening and confounding. Many of them were printouts of online correspondence between Barbara Potter and a mysterious man named Chris. The messages dated from 2011 to 2012. Barbara referred to Chris as son, and signed messages to him as mum. In turn, he ended his with, I love you all, your son, Chris.
警方并不知道波特家有一个儿子。芭芭拉主要向克里斯讲述了他们一家搬到山城后所遭受的骚扰。他们对比尔·佩恩、比利·琼·海沃思以及助长他们持续痛苦的比利·琼的朋友们有着共同的仇恨。许多信息都包含某种威胁，或是对这个群体施加暴力、伤害甚至死亡的渴望。芭芭拉和克里斯尤其为珍妮尔感到担忧，她承受了该群体恶意的最大冲击。克里斯称她为他的小妹妹，因为他从高中起就认识她了。阅读这些消息后，洛特特工觉得波特家的电脑会掌握更多线索。
The police were not aware of the Potters having a son. Barbara mostly spoke to Chris about the harassment her family had received following their move to Mountain City. They shared a mutual hatred for Bill Payne, Billie Jean Hayworth, and Billie Jean's friends for fueling their ongoing grief. Many of the messages included some sort of threat or desire for violence, harm, or death to the group. Barbara and Chris were particularly worried for Janelle, who bore the brunt of the group's maliciousness. Chris referred to her as his little sister, as he had known her since high school. Reading these messages, Agent Lott felt that the Potters computer would hold more clues.
幸运的是，从波特家中没收的绿色螺旋笔记本里包含了一份该家庭社交媒体和电子邮箱账户的用户名和密码列表。但由于他们怀疑那里的许多通信可能已被删除，调查人员还获得了传票，以获取该家庭电子邮箱和互联网提供商的记录。洛特特工收到了一张包含 20,000 多封电子邮件的光盘。其中有些内容格外引人注目。一月中旬，芭芭拉给自己发送了两个链接：“上帝能原谅一个谋杀犯吗？”以及“关于宽恕和谋杀的问题”。为什么在比尔和比利·琼被杀前两周，芭芭拉会琢磨上帝是否能原谅谋杀犯呢？
Fortunately, the green spiral notebook seized from the Potters home contained a list of usernames and passwords to the family's social media and email accounts. But as they suspected that many of the communications there might have been deleted, investigators also obtained subpoenas for records from the family's email and internet providers. Agent Lott received a DVD containing over 20,000 emails. Something stood out among them. In mid-January, Barbara had sent herself two links. Can God forgive a murderer? And questions about forgiveness and murder? Why would Barbara be wondering about whether God could forgive murderers two weeks before Bill and Billie Jean were killed?
对调查人员来说，查明芭芭拉每天发信息的神秘克里斯究竟是谁至关重要。谋杀案发生前一年，克里斯第一次给芭芭拉发电子邮件，写道：“嗨，芭芭拉，你好吗？希望你一切都好。是的，我是克里斯，又名科迪。听到发生这一切我很难过。希望有什么办法能帮到你们大家。”他透露自己一直在山城话题论坛上，并看到了针对波特一家的蔑视。他承认自己在网页上发表评论为他们辩护，因为网站管理员对这种有毒言论无动于衷。他向芭芭拉保证他已经处理好了。但事情非但没有停止，反而升级了。
It was important for investigators to uncover who the mysterious Chris was that Barbara messaged daily. One year before the murders, Chris emailed Barbara for the first time, writing, Hi Barbara, how are you? I hope you are well. Yes, this is Chris, aka Cody. I'm so sorry to hear all of that is going on. I wish there was a way to help you all. He revealed that he had been on the Mountain City Topics forum and had seen the disdain towards the Potters. He admitted to commenting on the pages in their defense, as the side administrators were doing nothing about the toxicity. He assured Barbara he had taken care of it. But rather than stop, things escalated.
有一天，珍妮尔向母亲展示了一封她收到来自比利·琼的朋友琳德丝·托马斯的电子邮件。上面写着：“你这个贱人是我的了。你是个他妈的碧池。记住，我能搞定你，也一定会这么做。你老爸对我无可奈何。我凌驾于法律之上，你这个愚蠢的臭婊子。”在此之后，波特一家成了当地警察局的常客，他们前往报案，投诉那些针对珍妮尔的人。在一块石头被扔向波特住所后，警察也被叫到了现场。石头的一侧写着“比利·佩恩”，另一侧写着“比利·琼”，还有一句名言：“我是你的好帮手（I'm your huckleberry）。”警察并没有认真对待这场宿怨，也没有采取任何措施来安抚波特一家。当芭芭拉通过电子邮件向克里斯表达她对
One day, Janelle showed her mother an email she had received from Billie Jean's friend Lindsey Thomas. It read, Your ass is mine. You're a fucking bitch. Remember that I can get you and will. Your daddy can't do shit to me. I'm above the law, dumb fucking bitch. Following this, the Potters became regular visitors to the local police station, where they lodged complaints about those targeting Janelle. Police were also called to the Potter residence after a rock had been thrown at the house. It had Billie Payne written on one side, Billie Jean on another, and the quote, I'm your huckleberry. The police didn't take the feud seriously, and nothing was done to placate the Potters. When Barbara expressed her irritation at the
警方不作为的愤怒时，他称强生县的执法部门又蠢又不可信。他知道许多当地警官的名字，并认为他们既无能又低效。克里斯向芭芭拉保证，如果有人伤害珍妮尔，他会做他受过训练要做的事。从两人的讨论中很明显，克里斯为中情局工作，并通过这一点与巴迪·波特有联系。他提到在职责范围内枪杀过人，并声称他在俄罗斯和纽约处理过一些人。他告诉芭芭拉：“我知道不是你死就是我活，所以我不得不杀人，但我现在喜欢开枪，杀人对我来说一点困扰也没有。”芭芭拉告诉他：“只要你是为人类做正确的事，你就不会受到严厉的评判。”
lack of police action to Chris via email, he called Johnson County law enforcement dumb and untrustworthy. He knew the names of many local officers and deemed them incompetent and ineffective. Chris promised Barbara that if anyone harmed Janelle that he would do what he was trained to do. It was clear from the pair's discussions that Chris worked for the CIA, and through this had connections to Buddy Potter. He mentioned shooting people in the line of duty and claimed he had gotten rid of people in Russia and in New York. He told Barbara, I knew it was us or them, so I had to kill, but I love to shoot now, and killing does not bother me at all. Barbara let him know, as long as you are doing the right thing for mankind, then you will not be judged badly.
由于克里斯通过电子邮件指责警方不作为，他称约翰逊县的执法部门愚蠢且不值得信任。他知道许多当地警官的名字，并认为他们无能且低效。克里斯向芭芭拉保证，如果有人伤害了詹妮尔，他会按照受过的训练去做。从两人的讨论中可以明显看出，克里斯为中央情报局工作，并通过这一渠道与巴迪·波特建立了联系。他提到了在执行公务时向人开枪，并声称自己在俄罗斯和纽约处理过一些人。他告诉芭芭拉：“我知道不是你死就是我活，所以我不得不杀人，但我现在很喜欢射击，杀人对我一点困扰也没有。”芭芭拉则告诉他，只要你是为人类做正确的事，你就不会受到严厉的审判。
You are helping others by getting rid of the bad. Chris expressed the desire to kill the Mountain City residents that had caused the Potters grief, including Johnson County Sheriff Mike Reese for his inaction. However, there were always reasons he couldn't carry out the slayings himself. He guaranteed that if Buddy took matters into his own hands, he would be protected by the CIA. This encouraged Barbara into thinking that violent action should be taken against her foes, as her family would be safe from repercussions. She badgered Chris to talk to his superiors to have Buddy's CIA identification reissued so that he could get access to CIA guns.
通过清除恶势力，你是在帮助他人。克里斯曾表达过杀害那些给波特一家带来痛苦的山城居民的强烈愿望，其中包括因无所作为而遭到痛恨的约翰逊县治安官迈克·里斯。然而，他总有各种理由无法亲自执行这些谋杀。他向巴迪保证，如果他亲自动手，他将受到中情局的庇护。这促使芭芭拉认为，对她的敌人采取暴力行动是正当的，因为她的家人将免受任何惩罚。她一再纠缠克里斯，让他去找上级重新签发巴迪的中情局身份证明，以便他能获得中情局的枪支。
Barbara explained that Buddy was fed up and ready, and although a very patient man had been pushed too hard for too long. As Buddy didn't use a computer, Barbara would print out any important information from Chris, pass it on, then destroy the paper. One day, Buddy was handed yet another printout of an email from Chris. He had written that if Buddy decided to do anything, he should get Bill Payne first, because, quote, he's really mean and an asshole. The emails confused investigators. On the one hand, they were certain that Chris was not a law enforcement operative. It was extremely unlikely a CIA agent would write
芭芭拉解释说，巴迪已经忍无可忍、蓄势待发了；尽管他是个极有耐心的人，但长期以来被逼得太紧。由于巴迪不用电脑，芭芭拉便会把克里斯发来的任何重要信息打印出来，转交给巴迪，然后将纸张销毁。一天，巴迪又拿到了一份打印出来的克里斯的电子邮件。信中写道，如果巴迪决定采取行动，他应该先解决掉比尔·佩恩，因为，引述原话，他真是个刻薄的混蛋。这些邮件让调查人员感到困惑。一方面，他们确信克里斯并非执法人员。中情局特工极不可能写出
things like, I'm going to run into Haw, Slutface, ugly as a mudface bitch, and her fucker of a boyfriend. Or would take an interest in such an ordinary family as the Potters and the petty internet drama that surrounded them. The whole scenario seemed off. However, Chris was a very real person. Janelle Potter's introduction on her online MySpace page included the paragraph. Then I have Chris. I have known him for a very long, long time. He's a cop in Pennsylvania. He's a good guy and a true friend, and almost like a brother to me, and married to a wonderful girl named Megan. I wish nothing but the best for you both.
诸如“我要撞上霍、荡妇、丑得像泥脸一样的碧池，还有她那混蛋男友”这样的话，也不会对波特一家这样普通以及环绕着他们的无聊网络闹剧产生兴趣。整个事件看起来很不正常。然而，克里斯是一个真实存在的人。珍妮尔·波特在她的在线MySpace个人主页上的介绍中包含了这样一段话：然后我有克里斯。我认识他已经有非常非常长的时间了。他是宾夕法尼亚州的一名警察。他是个好人，真正的朋友，对我来说几乎就像个亲兄弟一样，而且娶了一个名叫梅根的 maravilhosa（精彩/美妙，注：此处应为 wonderful）女孩。我祝愿你们俩一切都好。
Investigators were able to find photos of Chris, his dog, and his friends among the Potters' emails. One from Barbara's account had the subject line, Pick of Chris Our Son, and contained text that read, This is Chris Jaden back at youth camp with Janelle, age 18 or so. It was accompanied with a blurry photograph of two people wearing what appeared to be military fatigues. In one of her private Facebook messages, Barbara had written to a friend that Chris Jaden had helped Janelle fight bullies in school. Barbara called Chris her adopted son and said that the family loved him, but didn't get to see him often enough. So, if Chris Jaden really existed, just how involved was he in the murders of Bill Payne and Billie Jean Hayworth?
调查人员在波特一家的电子邮件中找到了克里斯、他的狗以及他的朋友们的照片。其中一封来自芭芭拉账号的邮件主题是“我们的儿子克里斯的照片”，正文写道：“这是克里斯·杰登在青年夏令营和珍妮尔在一起，大约18岁。”邮件附带了一张模糊的照片，照片上有两个人穿着类似军用迷彩服的衣服。在其中一条私密的Facebook消息中，芭芭拉曾向一位朋友写道，克里斯·杰登曾在学校里帮珍妮尔对抗霸凌者。芭芭拉称克里斯为她的养子，并表示全家人都很爱他，只是没能经常见到他。那么，如果克里斯·杰登真的存在，他究竟在谋杀比尔·佩恩和比利·珍·海沃斯一案中扮演了什么角色？
Investigators wanted answers. It was time to contact the man himself and find out what was going on. Christopher Jaden was a certified constable in Delaware and had previously worked for the city's police department. He revealed that he had attended high school with Janelle Potter, but his recollections didn't align with him seeing her as a sister. He recalled Janelle as being very strange. She was known to throw tantrums, have problems with classmates, and get in trouble a lot. Like most people, Chris kept his distance. He had two classes with Janelle and spoke to her occasionally, but they weren't part of the same friendship group. If he was nice to her, she would sometimes hang around, but he would extricate himself politely.
调查人员想要得到答案。是时候联系这位当事人，弄清楚到底发生了什么事。克里斯托弗·杰登是特拉华州的一名注册法警，此前曾在该市警察局工作过。他透露，他曾与珍妮尔·波特读同一所高中，但他的回忆并不符合他将她视作妹妹的说法。他回忆说珍妮尔非常古怪。她出了名的爱发脾气，与同学相处有问题，并且经常惹麻烦。和大多数人一样，克里斯与她保持着距离。他和珍妮尔有过两门同堂的课，偶尔会跟她说话，但他们并不是同一个朋友圈子的人。如果他对她好一点，她有时会赖着不走，但他会礼貌地抽身离开。
That was the extent of their interactions. She once sent him a friend request on Facebook, but he declined it. Chris had not had contact with Janelle since graduating from high school in 2000. He had never met any of the other Potters or anyone else from Mountain City. This raised the question, why would Barbara Potter call a man she had never met, her son? Although he worked in law enforcement, Chris had never served in the CIA. Chris looked at the photographs of him in the Potters' possession. Some were old profile pictures that had been lifted from his social media accounts. He didn't recognize the rest. Some were of men who looked like him,
这就是他们互动的全部程度。她曾在Facebook上向他发送好友请求，但他拒绝了。自2000年高中毕业以来，克里斯就再也没有和珍妮尔有过联系。他从未见过其他波特家人或山城来的任何人。这就引发了一个问题：为什么芭芭拉·波特会把一个素未谋面的人称为她的儿子？尽管克里斯从事执法工作，但他从未在中情局服役过。克里斯看着波特一家持有的关于他的照片。有些是旧的头像照片，是从他的社交媒体账号上盗取的。其余的他不认识。有些是长得像他的男人的照片，
or blurry photos in which the man featured could pass as him. He had never sent the family or anyone else involved with the Potters' pictures of himself. It didn't take long for Agent Lott to rule out the real-life Chris Jayden as having any part to play in the pain Hayworth murders. The revelation didn't come as a surprise though, and only served to confirm suspicions. The email that the phony Chris sent his messages from gave a very good indication as to his true identity. Like so many socially awkward young people, the internet was Janelle Potter's lifeline. In one post, she wrote of her move to Tennessee,
或者是照片中的男子可以蒙混过关的模糊照片。他从未向这家人或任何与波特一家有关的人发送过自己的照片。洛特特工没花多长时间就排除了现实生活中的克里斯·杰登参与海沃斯谋杀案的任何嫌疑。然而，这个揭秘并不让人意外，它只是证实了此前的怀疑。那个假冒的克里斯发送信息的电子邮箱非常明确地指明了他的真实身份。像许多社交笨拙的年轻人一样，互联网是珍妮尔·波特的生命线。在一篇帖子中，她写到了自己搬到田纳西州的事，
I love the friends that I have down here. They are sweet and wonderful people. In truth, Janelle had been struggling to build any authentic and reciprocal relationships since arriving in Mountain City. The locals were uncomfortable by her lack of social awareness and the way she acted overly familiar with them. Sometimes she went in for an unwelcome hug. She towered over other women standing at over six feet tall, but had a high-pitched child-like voice that didn't align with her large frame. That didn't stop Janelle from adding everyone she knew as well as people she didn't to her Facebook page. Online, she described herself as a loving and caring person who had been told she was too nice and so sweet. But she conceded,
我喜欢我在南边结交的朋友。他们都是甜美而美好的人。事实上，自从来到山城以来，珍妮尔一直难以建立任何真实且互惠的人际关系。当地人对她缺乏社交意识以及她对他们表现得过于熟络的方式感到不适。有时她会突然上前给人一个不受欢迎的拥抱。她身高超过六英尺，俯视着其他女性，却有着高亢的、孩子般的声音，这与她高大的身形很不相符。但这并没有阻止珍妮尔将她认识的所有人以及她不认识的人都加到她的Facebook页面上。在网上，她将自己描述为一个充满爱心和关怀的人，别人总是对她说她太好、太甜美了。但她也承认，
I do take things to heart and let things get to me. I try not to, but it's very hard. This was abundantly clear when she met Bill Payne, Billie Jean Hayworth, and her friends. Initially, things were cordial between them. But when Janelle started bombarding her newfound friends with messages, they were quickly fed up. Even if they appeared offline, Janelle still flooded their inboxes. When her messages went unread, she would call and text them. This intensity was off-putting and as a result, they all unfriended Janelle on Facebook. This would seem like a petty dispute that would quickly become a non-drama once those involved went their separate ways. However, Janelle's lack of maturity ensured she took it very seriously.
我确实会把事情往心里去，让事情影响到我。我尽量不去这样，但真的很难。当她遇到比尔·佩恩、比利·珍·海沃斯和她的朋友们时，这一点显露无疑。起初，他们之间的关系还算融洽。但当珍妮尔开始用大量信息狂轰滥炸她新结识的朋友时，他们很快就受够了。即便他们显示不在线，珍妮尔仍然不断用信息轰炸他们的收件箱。当她的消息无人阅读时，她就会打电话和发短信。这种强烈的纠缠令人反感，结果，他们都在Facebook上取消了加珍妮尔为好友。这本只是一场微不足道的争端，一旦涉事双方各奔东西，很快就会化为乌云散去。然而，珍妮尔的不成熟确保了她对此极其认真。
She vented on social media and the dispute caused quite the reaction on the Mountain City Topics forum. She relished in her newfound victim status, though many townsfolk noticed that what they were witnessing didn't match the potter's version of events. In real life, Billie Jean and her friends Lindsey Thomas and Tara Osborne faced upwards of 20 calls a day from the potter's home phone number. When they'd answer, Janelle would either breathe or scream down the line. They were forced to take their phones off the hook just for a reprieve. Lindsey Thomas filed a phone harassment charge against Janelle, her affidavit stating,
她在社交媒体上发泄不满，这场争端在山城话题论坛（Mountain City Topics forum）上引发了不小的反响。她很享受自己新获得的受害人身份，尽管许多镇民注意到他们所目睹的并不符合波特一家的版本。在现实生活中，比利·珍和她的朋友林赛·托马斯以及塔拉·奥斯本每天要面对来自波特家座机打来的多达20通电话。当他们接听时，珍妮尔要么在电话那头喘气，要么尖叫。他们被迫把电话机从插座上拔下来以求得片刻清静。林赛·托马斯对珍妮尔提起了电话骚扰指控，她的陈述书中写道：
This all started because I deleted her off my Facebook. However, the case was dismissed, as Lindsey was not able to satisfy the burden of proof beyond reasonable doubt that the calls were coming from Janelle. To Buddy and Barbara Potter, the court result proved their daughter was the innocent party and her toolmenters were liars. Janelle vehemently denied harassing any of her former friends, whom she took to referring as the mean girls. She maintained that she was the victim, with the harassment also occurring offline and embroiling her entire family. She shared copies of messages allegedly sent to her by her aggressors to her parents. One warned, Bill is going to kill you. He has said that and I hope he does. None of us want you around,
这一切都是因为我在Facebook上删除了她。然而，该案被驳回了，因为林赛无法提供足够的证据，在合理怀疑之外证明这些电话是珍妮尔打来的。对巴迪和芭芭拉·波特来说，法院的判决证明了他们的女儿是无辜的一方，而她的折磨者全都是骗子。珍妮尔坚决否认骚扰过任何前朋友——她后来习惯称她们为“刻薄女孩”。她坚持认为自己才是受害者，骚扰还发生在现实生活中，并牵连了她整个家族。她与父母分享了据称由她的施害者发给她的信息副本。其中一条警告说：比尔要杀了你。他已经说过了，我希望他真的这么做。我们谁都不希望你在周围，
nor living. You're a waste of air and time on everyone. You are nothing. Janelle informed the mean girls that she had spoken to the police and that, quote, They know that I'm not doing a thing. It was true that the Potters had visited the police station to report the mean girls. They spoke of living in fear, convinced that there were many people in town who would harm Janelle. Their accused told a different story. They claimed that Janelle was harassing them and denied authoring the threatening messages she said she received from them. Sheriff Mike Reese didn't know how to respond when Buddy Potter made a formal complaint about locals unfriending his daughter on Facebook. The sheriff just told him that
更不想让你活着。对每个人来说，你都是在浪费空气和时间。你什么都不是。珍妮尔通知那些刻薄女孩，说她已经跟警察谈过了，而且，“他们知道我什么都没做。”事实确是波特夫妇曾去警察局举报过这些刻薄女孩。他们诉说生活在恐惧之中，确信镇上有许多人会伤害珍妮尔。而被他们指控的人则讲述了不同的故事。他们声称是珍妮尔在骚扰他们，并否认撰写了她所说的那种威胁信息。当巴迪·波特就当地人在Facebook上取消关注他女儿好友资格一事进行正式投诉时，迈克·里斯治安官不知该如何回应。治安官只是告诉他，
unfriending someone was not illegal. When a rock was thrown at the Potters house with Bill Payne and Billie Jane Hayworth's names written on it, police were skeptical. Despite Buddy and Barbara's genuine fear that their daughter was in danger, the police didn't believe that Vandals would sign their names on evidence of their crime. Things continued to escalate, but mostly from the Potters side. One afternoon in mid-2011, Janelle and her mother confronted Billie Jean at a gas station. They screamed at her that she was, quote, white trash who did not deserve to be a mother. Billie Jean told a concerned onlooker, this won't stop. They follow me everywhere. They're constantly threatening me.
取消某人的好友资格并不违法。当一块写有比尔·佩恩和比利·珍·海沃斯名字的石头被扔向波特家时，警方持怀疑态度。尽管巴迪和芭芭拉真诚地担心他们的女儿处于危险之中，但警方不相信破坏者会在他们犯罪的证据上签上自己的名字。事情继续升级，但主要来自波特一家。2011年中期的一个下午，珍妮尔和她的母亲在一家加油站与比利·珍发生对质。她们冲着她尖叫，说她是“不配为人母的白色垃圾”。比利·珍对一位关切的旁观者说：“这不会停止的。他们到处跟踪我。他们一直在威胁我。”
While visiting a grocery store, Buddy Potter told a staff member that if he had a chance, he was going to put a bullet through Bill Payne's head. Throughout the duration of the feud, Barbara Potter was communicating with longtime family friend and CIA agent Chris. The pair went back and forth sharing their hatred of Janelle's rivals while compelling each other to do something drastic about it. Barbara had never met Chris in real life, but knew him well enough through Janelle to consider him a son. She didn't find it at all suspicious that all the communications she received from Chris were coming from her daughter's personal email. Chris said this was to ensure his CIA credentials
在一家杂货店购物时，巴迪·波特对一名员工说，如果有机会，他要在比尔·佩恩的脑袋里开个洞。在整场争端期间，芭芭拉·波特一直在与多年的家族朋友兼中情局特工克里斯保持联系。两人反复交流，分享对珍妮尔对手的仇恨，同时敦促对方对此采取激烈的行动。芭芭拉在现实生活中从未见过克里斯，但通过珍妮尔对他相当熟悉，甚至将他视为儿子。她一点也不觉得奇怪的是，她从克里斯那里收到的所有通讯都是从她女儿的个人邮箱发出的。克里斯说这是为了确保他的中情局身份证明
wouldn't be compromised. Barbara accepted this explanation. When Jamie Curd first met Janelle Potter, it was an unremarkable experience. The pair had been set up in part by Jamie's cousin, Bill Payne. Since she had met Bill through mutual friends, many suspected that Janelle had a crush on him. He kept things platonic. Both Jamie and Janelle were Mountain City's lonely misfits, and Bill thought they'd make a good match instead. Despite a lackluster introduction, Janelle asked for Jamie's phone number and a relationship quickly blossomed. Janelle called Jamie often, but the calls were no more than 45 seconds. They had to be brief because she didn't want her parents to know they were talking.
不会泄露。芭芭拉接受了这种解释。当杰米·柯德第一次见到珍妮尔·波特时，这是一次平平无奇的经历。两人是在杰米的表哥比尔·佩恩的撮合下认识的。既然她是通过共同的朋友认识比尔的，许多人怀疑珍妮尔对比尔有好感。但他俩的关系一直保持在纯洁的柏拉图式。杰米和珍妮尔都是山城孤独的边缘人，比尔认为他们俩会很合得来。尽管初次见面平淡无奇，但珍妮尔还是索要了杰米的电话号码，两人的关系迅速发展。珍妮尔经常给杰米打电话，但通话时间从未超过45秒。他们必须长话短说，因为她不想让父母知道他们在通话。
Buddy and Barbara Potter didn't like Jamie. They felt he was beneath them and a bad influence. While Jamie wanted to prove himself worthy, it was the first time he had a girlfriend, so he respected Janelle's desire to keep things secret. When Janelle mentioned she was having computer problems, Jamie saw an opportunity to get inside the Potter residence to see her. When Buddy and Barbara deduced that Jamie had feelings for their daughter, they were not pleased. He wasn't good enough for their beloved Janelle, and they would never permit the pair to date. Jamie purchased Janelle a cell phone so they
巴迪和芭芭拉·波特不喜欢杰米。他们觉得他配不上他们，而且是个坏影响。虽然杰米想证明自己的价值，这也是他第一次交女朋友，所以他尊重珍妮尔想要保密的愿望。当珍妮尔提到她的电脑遇到问题时，杰米看到了一个能进入波特住所去看她的机会。当巴迪和芭芭拉推断出杰米对他们的女儿有意思时，他们很不高兴。他配不上他们心爱的珍妮尔，他们绝不允许两人约会。杰米给珍妮尔买了一部手机，以便他们
could speak behind her parents' back. When Barbara discovered this phone, Jamie got Janelle another. After five or six months, Jamie and Janelle began to talk about eloping. Janelle snuck out of her home one night to wed Jamie, but he got drunk and failed to meet up with her. Buddy was furious when he learned of what the pair had planned and chewed Jamie out over the phone, saying that his daughter didn't love him. He then passed the phone to Janelle, who confirmed what her father had said. Although Jamie agreed to stop talking to Janelle, she called him days later. She said she loved him and wanted to keep their secret relationship going.
可以在她父母背后通话。当芭芭拉发现这部手机时，杰米又给珍妮尔弄了一部。五六个月后，杰米和珍妮尔开始谈论私奔。一天晚上，珍妮尔偷偷溜出家门去和杰米结婚，但他喝醉了，没能去赴约。当巴迪得知两人的计划时勃然大怒，在电话里狠狠训斥了杰米，说他女儿根本不爱他。然后他把电话递给珍妮尔，珍妮尔证实了她父亲所说的话。尽管杰米同意不再和珍妮尔说话，但几天后她又打电话给他。她说她爱他，并希望继续他们秘密的恋爱关系。
They went back to their old ways. When Jamie's mother passed away in May 2011, he received a call from Barbara Potter expressing her condolences. Jamie was his mother's caregiver, and the loss hit him hard. For the first time, Barbara showed Jamie compassion and told him to call her if he ever needed anything. She also invited him around for dinner. The Potters continued to show Jamie kindness, hosting him on holidays and allowing him to visit.
他们回到了老样子。2011年5月，当杰米的母亲去世时，他接到了芭芭拉·波特打来的表示哀悼的电话。杰米一直是母亲的照顾者，丧母之痛对他的打击很大。芭芭拉破天荒地对杰米表现出同情，并告诉他如果需要任何帮助随时给她打电话。她还邀请他过去吃晚饭。波特一家继续向杰米表现出善意，邀请他过节并允许他来访。
It had taken years, but Jamie Curd had finally been accepted by Buddy and Barbara Potter. Buddy took him out shooting, and Barbara treated him to homemade cake. Though, things were never at the point where Jamie could openly date Janelle. He never pressed the matter, in fear they would shun him again, and he wouldn't be able to see Janelle at all. His desire to see her ensured he remained loyal to the family and did everything they asked. Barbara and Janelle brought Jamie up to speed on the hassles they were having with the mean girls. They believed they were targeting Janelle due to jealousy over how pretty she was.
花了多年的时间，杰米·柯德终于被巴迪和芭芭拉·波特接受了。巴迪带他去打靶，芭芭拉用自制蛋糕款待他。不过，事情远没有发展到杰米可以公开与珍妮尔约好的地步。他从不敢催促此事，生怕他们再次疏远他，那样他就彻底见不到珍妮尔了。想要见她的渴望确保了他对这个家族保持绝对忠诚，并言听计从。芭芭拉和珍妮尔向杰米详细讲述了她们与那些刻薄女孩之间的种种烦心事。她们认为这些女孩针对珍妮尔纯粹是出于嫉妒她长得太漂亮。
Jamie was an on-face book and didn't care much for social media, so Janelle forwarded him the threatening messages her enemies sent her. Jamie was shocked at the nasty abuse being hurled at Janelle, especially as Janelle was such an innocent and gentle person. He was still working with Bill, but tensions were rising between the two. Jamie was deeply in love with Janelle and took the Potter side of the feud against his cousin. It got bad enough that their employer had to assign them to different shifts. Now that she had accepted him as a family friend,
杰米不上Facebook，也不怎么关注社交媒体，所以珍妮尔把她那些敌人发来的威胁信息转发给了他。杰米对那些泼向珍妮尔的恶毒虐待感到震惊，尤其是珍妮尔本身是个如此天真温柔的人。他仍然在和比尔一起工作，但两人之间的紧张关系正在加剧。杰米深深地爱着珍妮尔，在这场争端中，他站在波特一家一边对抗他的表哥。情况变得如此糟糕，以至于他们的雇主不得不把他们分到不同的班次。既然她已经接受他为家族朋友，
Barbara began to write long, rambling emails to Jamie. They were always about how her family was being targeted for attack. The emails sometimes ran over 10 pages long. Jamie began visiting the Potter residents more frequently. Each time, Barbara would monopolize the conversation with rants about the mean girls. Janelle remained silent during these discussions. Jamie noted that when she spoke to him on the phone, Janelle was opinionated, but around her parents, she acted needy and childlike.
芭芭拉开始给杰米写长篇大论、语无伦次的电子邮件。内容总是围绕着她的家族如何成为被攻击的目标。这些邮件有时甚至长达10多页。杰米开始更频繁地拜访波特家。每一次，芭芭拉都会垄断谈话，滔滔不绝地抱怨那些刻薄女孩。在这些讨论中，珍妮尔一直保持沉默。杰米注意到，当她在电话里跟自己说话时，珍妮尔很有主见，但在父母周围，她却表现得像个依赖人的孩子。
Barbara characterized the feud as like a war. Janelle had often come home in tears with tales of plots to harm, kidnap, and rape her and to hurt her family. Barbara demanded to know what Jamie and Buddy were going to do about it. Despite Buddy being the armed to the teeth ex-CIA agent, Jamie was more afraid of Barbara. He would walk on eggshells around her in fear his house visits would be revoked. He listened to her tirades and nodded and agreed,
芭芭拉将这场争端形容为一场战争。珍妮尔经常哭着回家，讲述各种密谋要伤害、绑架、强奸她以及伤害她家人的阴谋。芭芭拉逼问杰米和巴迪打算对此做些什么。尽管巴迪是那个武装到牙齿的前中情局特工，但杰米其实更害怕芭芭拉。他在她面前如履薄冰，生怕自己的家访资格被剥夺。他听着她的狂躁演说，不住地点头表示同意，
hoping it would earn him an invitation to dinner or even a family outing. Soon, Jamie began receiving emails from Chris. He expressed concern that Janelle would be hospitalized due to the stress and feared she was suicidal. Jamie responded, Jamie responded, I think that if it wasn't for us, she might have thought about it. I can tell she has just taken all she can take from those motherfuckers.
希望这能为他赢得一次共进晚餐甚至家庭出游的邀请。不久，杰米开始收到来自克里斯的电子邮件。他在信中表达了对珍妮尔因压力过大而可能需要住院治疗的担忧，并担心她有自杀倾向。杰米回复道，杰米回复道：“我想如果不是我们的话，她可能已经动过这个念头了。我看得出来，她已经承受了那些王八蛋所能带给她的一切极限。”
They won't let up and they're crazy. Hell, I don't know why they have to do this. Jamie was led to believe he too was in grave danger. Chris warned him that the CIA had since discovered that Billie Jean was urging Bill to kill Jamie because he sided with the Potters. Should Jamie defend himself, Chris assured him, I've got your back. Jamie, like Barbara and Buddy, never questioned why all the correspondence he had with Chris
他们绝不罢休，而且他们都是疯子。见鬼，我不知道他们为什么非要这么做。杰米被引导着相信自己也身处极度危险之中。克里斯警告他，中情局此后发现比利·珍正在怂恿比尔杀死杰米，因为杰米站在了波特一家一边。如果杰米自卫，克里斯向他保证：“我为你撑腰。”杰米和芭芭拉、巴迪一样，从未质疑过为什么他与克里斯的所有通信
was through accounts owned by Janelle. When Janelle let it slip to Jamie that she was going to have to start calling Lindsay Thomas again, she got real defensive and wouldn't say anything else about it. The remark fell by the wayside and no one pressed her for the truth of the matter. By then, the Potters had reached breaking point. Barbara wrote to Jamie, they are trying to kill Janelle little by little, but Doc says that at this rate it could happen any time with a heart attack or stroke. The stress has to stop.
都是通过珍妮尔名下的账号进行的。当珍妮尔不小心向杰米说漏嘴她不得不重新开始给林赛·托马斯打电话时，她变得异常戒备，再也不肯多说半句话。这句话就这样被抛在脑后，也没有人追问事情的真相。到那时，波特一家已经到了崩溃的边缘。芭芭拉写信给杰米：“他们正试图一点一点地害死珍妮尔，但医生说照这样下去，随时可能突发心脏病或中风。这种压力必须停止了。”
She said the attacks would not end until we're all dead or gone, and that Chris had told her the cops are behind Billie Jean. More than anyone, Bill Payne was sick of the drama. He continued to try and smooth things over with the Potters. He told them that Janelle was lying to them as well as the rest of the world, but they were having none of it. Leave us alone, Barbara yelled at Bill. If you call here again, I'm going to do something about it.
她说，除非我们所有人都死了或消失了，否则这些攻击是不会停止的，而且克里斯告诉她，警察都在包庇比利·珍。比尔·佩恩比任何人都厌烦这出闹剧。他继续试图和波特一家化解矛盾。他告诉他们，珍妮尔不仅在对他们撒谎，也在对全世界撒谎，但他们根本听不进去。“离我们远点，”芭芭拉冲着比尔大喊。“如果你再打电话来，我就要采取行动了。”
As Barbara, Chris, Buddy and Jamie talked about what needed to be done, it became clear that there was only one solution. The group believed Janelle's tormentors were never going to stop unless they were made to stop. It was getting late on January 30, 2012, when Jamie Curd's phone rang. It was Barbara Potter. She had a bill that needed to be paid online by midnight and claimed her computer was locking up and preventing her from doing so. Jamie headed to the Potter house to help out.
随着芭芭拉、克里斯、巴迪和杰米讨论需要做些什么，很明显，只有一个解决方案。这个群体认为，除非强行让珍妮尔的折磨者停手，否则他们永远不会罢休。2012年1月30日天色渐晚时，杰米·柯德的电话响了。打电话来的是芭芭拉·波特。她有一笔账单需要在午夜前在网上支付，并声称她的电脑死机了，导致她无法完成操作。杰米前往波特家帮忙。
Buddy entered the computer room while Jamie was in there alone. He wanted Jamie to do him a favor. Buddy asked Jamie to take him down next to poor Bill's house, let him out, go down the road, and come back and pick him up. He didn't say when, but Jamie agreed. Not long after Jamie got back home, Janelle called him to tell him Buddy needed his help to do something. He then got a text message from Janelle that read,
当杰米独自一人在电脑室时，巴迪走了进来。他想让杰米帮他一个忙。巴迪要求杰米开车带他去可怜的比尔家附近，让他下车，然后杰米把车开到路上，过一会儿再回来接他。他没有说具体时间，但杰米答应了。杰米回到家没多久，珍妮尔就打电话告诉他，巴迪需要他的帮忙去办点事。接着他收到珍妮尔发来的一条短信，上面写着：
I would not take your cell phone with you in the morning. Jamie replied, I'm not going to. The text message is finished with Janelle writing, I love you, my husband. In the early hours of the following morning, Jamie's home phone rang. It stopped before he could reach it. The caller ID showed that the call had come from the Potter residence. He tried to call back, but there was no answer.
你早上最好别把手机带在身上。杰米回复道：我不会带的。短信的结尾是珍妮尔写道：我爱你，我的丈夫。第二天清晨，杰米家里的座机响了。在他赶到接听之前，铃声就停了。来电显示表明这通电话来自波特家。他试图回拨，但无人接听。
It was 4.25am, but Janelle was awake. She sent Jamie a text instructing him to call back. Buddy answered and asked if Jamie could do that favor for him that morning. Jamie agreed, and moments later, Janelle sent him several messages in rapid succession, saying her father was leaving, and telling Jamie to text as soon as he got back. The son hadn't yet risen when Buddy's black Ford F-250 pulled up.
当时是凌晨4点25分，但珍妮尔已经醒了。她给杰米发了一条短信，指示他回电话。巴迪接了电话，问杰米那天早上能不能帮他那个忙。杰米答应了，片刻之后，珍妮尔连续快速发来几条消息，说她父亲正要出门，并告诉杰米一回来就发短信。太阳还没升起，巴迪黑色的福特F-250皮卡就开了过来。
Jamie left his cell behind as Janelle had instructed, and climbed into the car. The two men drove to a parking lot across a field from poor Bill's house. They waited until they saw the headlights of a pickup truck cut through the darkness, signifying that poor Bill had left for work. Buddy motioned for Jamie to follow him, and started across the field on foot. They hid behind a shed outside the car,
杰米按照珍妮尔的指示把手机留在了家里，然后钻进了车里。两个男人开车来到可怜的比尔家隔着一片田野的停车场。他们一直等到看到一束皮卡车的车头灯划破黑暗，这标志着可怜的比尔已经出门去上班了。巴迪示意杰米跟着他，开始步行穿过田野。他们躲在车外的一个棚子后面，
they hid behind a shed out the back of the house, where Jamie told Buddy that if Bill saw them, all hell's gonna break loose. Buddy handed Jamie a gun while keeping another for himself. Jamie looked down at the weapon, a chill running down his spine. I couldn't kill no one, he told the older man. Buddy responded that he just needed Jamie to stand at that door. Jamie had never seen Buddy like this before.
他们躲在房子后门外的棚子后面，杰米在那里对巴迪说，如果比尔看到他们，一定会天翻地覆。巴迪把一把枪递给杰米，自己留了一把。杰米看着手中的武器，脊背一阵发凉。“我谁也杀不了，”他对这位年长的男子说。巴迪回答说，他只需要杰米站在那扇门口。杰米从未见过巴迪这个样子。
It was as if his CIA training had kicked in, and he was a man on a mission. The pair entered through the rear sliding glass door, which was, as usual, unlocked. Jamie stood guard as ordered, while Buddy strode down the hallway and entered the first bedroom. Jamie heard his cousin utter the last words he would ever say, what the hell? Billie Jean fled from the room as a gunshot rang out. Moments later, Buddy emerged and looked at Jamie.
就好像他的中情局训练被激活了一样，他成了一个肩负使命的人。两人从后方的推拉玻璃门进入，这扇门和往常一样没有上锁。杰米按吩咐站岗放哨，而巴迪大步走过走廊，进入了第一间卧室。杰米听到他的表哥说出了他这辈子留下的最后一句话：“搞什么鬼？”随着一声枪响，比利·珍从房间里逃了出来。片刻之后，巴迪走了出来，看着杰米。
Jamie pointed down the hallway where Billie Jean had run to. Buddy took off in that direction. Jamie left his post to look inside the first bedroom, and saw his cousin lying on the bed, blood pooling around him. When Jamie heard another gunshot, he ran from the house back to Buddy's truck. Buddy was not far behind. Jamie returned his gun to him, before Buddy dropped him off at the end of his driveway, where Jamie promptly threw up.
杰米指向比利·珍逃跑的走廊方向。巴迪朝那个方向冲了过去。杰米离开岗位，朝第一间卧室里面看去，只见他的表哥躺在床上，周围聚满了鲜血。当杰米听到又一声枪响时，他从房子里跑回了巴迪的卡车。巴迪紧随其后。杰米把枪还给他，随后巴迪把他送到他家车道的尽头，杰米当场就吐了出来。
A short while later, Jamie received a text from CIA agent Chris that said, the problem was over. A year and a half after the murders of Bill Payne and Billie Jean Hayworth, agent Scott Lott arrived at Johnston Memorial Hospital in Virginia. Barbara Potter was inside. She was looking after daughter Janelle, who had been hospitalized for one of her many ailments. Officers charged Barbara with two counts of first-degree murder, and conspiracy to commit first-degree murder.
不久后，杰米收到中情局特工克里斯发来的一条短信，上面写着：问题已经解决了。在比尔·佩恩和比利·珍·海沃斯被谋杀一年半后，斯科特·洛特特工抵达了弗吉尼亚州的约翰斯顿纪念医院。芭芭拉·波特就在里面。她在照顾女儿珍妮尔，后者因她的诸多病痛之一而住院。警官们以两项一级谋杀罪和共谋一级谋杀罪对芭芭拉提出了指控。
In a twist that many saw coming, Janelle was charged with the same offences. Despite Jamie Curd and Buddy and Barbara Potter playing a part, investigators had little doubt that Janelle Potter was the mastermind behind the double homicide. Catfishing refers to a form of deception, wherein a person creates a fake persona online in order to form a relationship with another person. Motivations vary and include financial gain, to compromise or upset the victim in some way, or wish fulfillment.
在一个许多人预料之中的转折中，珍妮尔也被指控了相同的罪名。尽管杰米·柯德以及巴迪和芭芭拉·波特都参与其中，但调查人员对珍妮尔·波特是这起双重谋杀案的幕后主使毫无疑虑。“扮猫钓鱼”（Catfishing）指的是一种欺诈形式，即一个人在网上创建一个虚假身份，以便与另一个人建立关系。其动机各不相同，包括获取经济利益、以某种方式损害或激怒受害者，或者实现愿望。
Usually, the catfisher doesn't know the person they are fooling outside the internet. Other times, it is someone well known to the clueless victim. When they spoke of CIA agent Chris, Jamie, Barbara and Buddy did so, believing he was a very real person, who was exactly as he portrayed himself to be. The trio trusted Chris, certain he was an old friend of Janelle's, despite never having met him themselves. The Chris they knew, however, was a catfish. Several factors could have contributed to them not seeing through the deception.
通常情况下，“钓鱼者”在互联网之外并不认识他们正在愚弄的人。有时，则是无知的受害者非常熟悉的人。当他们谈论中情局特工克里斯时，杰米、芭芭拉和巴迪深信他是一个真实存在的人，并且完全如他所表现的那样。这三个人信任克里斯，坚信他是珍妮尔的老朋友，尽管他们自己从未见过他。然而，他们认识的那个克里斯却是一个骗子。有几个因素可能导致他们没有识破这个骗局。
Whether it was their level of education, their naivety, their inability to think critically, or just tunnel vision with the feud, at no point did anyone who spoke online with Chris ever question his identity. No one noticed that Chris's spelling, grammar and punctuation were similar to someone they spoke to daily for years. There were some differences. Chris would rant and curse and wish pain and death. Janelle, on the other hand, hated cursing, and her writing was always sweet and loving, with no threats of violence. Yet, it was clear as day to investigators examining the pages upon pages of communications published by Chris, he was Janelle Potter.
无论是他们的受教育程度、他们的天真、他们缺乏批判性思维能力，还是仅仅对这场争端带有“隧道视野”，在任何时候，任何与克里斯在网上交谈过的人都没有对他的身份产生过怀疑。没有人注意到克里斯的拼写、语法和标点符号与他们每天交谈了多年的人非常相似。确实存在一些差异。克里斯会大发雷霆、咒骂并祈求痛苦和死亡。另一方面，珍妮尔痛恨咒骂，她的文字总是甜美而充满爱意，没有任何暴力威胁。然而，对于审查克里斯发表的成页成页通信内容的调查人员来说，真相犹如白昼般清晰：他就是珍妮尔·波特。
Janelle had invented the online persona of Chris. Masquerading as him, she was able to manipulate her mother to convince her gallible father and boyfriend to murder her enemies. As Chris, Janelle pressured her parents to act. Chris wrote to Barbara that Bill Payne was spreading rumors that Buddy was involved in drug dealing and had plans to kill Janelle. Others, including Janelle's foes, failed to convince the Potters that their daughter was lying about what was really going on. Bill Payne once provided Buddy Potter a two-inch thick folder of documents that proved Janelle was the aggressor. Janelle's social media had never been hacked and there was no bounty on the
珍妮尔虚构了克里斯这个网络形象。她伪装成他的身份，成功操纵了母亲，进而说服了她轻信的父亲和男友去谋杀她的敌人。化身克里斯的珍妮尔向父母施压，让他们采取行动。克里斯写信给芭芭拉，称比尔·佩恩在散布谣言，说巴迪参与贩毒并计划杀害珍妮尔。其他人，包括珍妮尔的敌人在内，都未能说服波特一家相信他们的女儿在真实情况上撒了谎。比尔·佩恩曾给巴迪·波特提供了一份两英寸厚的文件夹，里面的文件证明珍妮尔才是挑起事端的人。珍妮尔的社交媒体从未被黑过，也没有人悬赏买下
Potters' heads. Bill even tried to impress upon Jamie that Janelle was behind many of the usernames fueling the online hostilities. He even doubted that Chris was a real person. Despite this, Jamie, Barbara, and Buddy wouldn't allow themselves to think of Janelle as anything else but an innocent and sweet person. It took almost a year, but Janelle's incessant emails and messages had the intended effect. Her mother, father, and boyfriend were all willing to kill for her, and they did. She had washed her hands of her involvement. There was plenty of evidence of Chris explicitly expressing a desire to kill Janelle's rivals, but there was no evidence of her ever making such requests. But her deception didn't stop there. She also authored many of
波特一家的脑袋。比尔甚至试图让杰米明白，珍妮尔是助长网络敌意的许多用户名的幕后黑手。他甚至怀疑克里斯是否是个真人。尽管如此，杰米、芭芭拉和巴迪还是不愿让自己把珍妮尔想象成一个纯真甜美之人以外的任何形象。花了将近一年的时间，珍妮尔没完没了的电子邮件和信息终于达到了预期的效果。她的母亲、父亲和男友都愿意为她杀人，而且他们也确实这么做了。她已经将自己撇得一干二净。有大量证据表明克里斯明确表达了杀害珍妮尔对手的愿望，但没有任何证据表明她曾提出过这样的要求。然而她的骗局并未就此停止。她还撰写了许多
the abusive social media messages and emails she claimed were from her harassers. Janelle was nothing if not prolific in her writing. She orchestrated an intricate web of deceit to paint herself as a victim and elicit sympathy. Most other people who observed the online bickering noticed the patterns in the posts by those who jumped in to defend Janelle, and it was obvious they were all one person. It was only after he had committed murder for the woman he loved that Jamie was embarrassed and ashamed to admit that he had been played. He wondered if Janelle had ever loved him at all, or if she simply saw him as a means to get what she wanted. Buddy Potter was tried alone in October 2013. The prosecution described him as someone who
她声称来自骚扰者的辱骂性社交媒体信息和电子邮件。珍妮尔在写作上可以说是极其高产。她精心策划了一个错综复杂的欺诈网络，把自己包装成受害者以博取同情。大多数其他观察这场网络口水战的人都注意到，那些跳出来为珍妮尔辩护的人的发帖模式有着明显的相似之处，很显然他们其实都是同一个人。直到为他所爱的女人犯下谋杀罪之后，杰米才感到难堪和羞耻，承认自己被耍了。他纳闷珍妮尔是否真的爱过他，还是仅仅把他当成实现自己目的的工具。巴迪·波特于2013年10月独自受审。检方将他描述为一个
was cold enough, calculating enough, and trained enough to be able to conduct murders like that, before saying, at least he thinks he is. He likes to tell people he's that kind of person. He likes for his family to think he's that kind of person. The truth was that Buddy Potter was never a part of the CIA, though he managed to convince his family otherwise. He also lied about being in the military. The Potters had left their previous town in shame after Buddy was convicted of stolen valor. Although dozens of firearms had been seized from the Potter household, the gun used to kill the victims hadn't been found. However, an expert testified that loose, unspent rounds found in
冷酷、精于算计且受过足够训练、能够执行此类谋杀的人，随后说道：“至少他自己是这么认为的。他喜欢告诉别人他是那种人。他喜欢让他的家人认为他是那种人。”事实是，巴迪·波特从未加入过中情局，尽管他设法让家人相信了这一点。他还谎称自己当过兵。在巴迪因“窃取荣誉”被定罪后，波特一家在一片耻辱中离开了他们以前的城镇。尽管从波特家中缴获了数十支枪械，但用来杀害受害者的那把枪却一直没有找到。不过，一位专家作证说，在
Buddy's truck matched the rounds found at the crime scene. The jury also got to listen to recorded phone calls between Buddy and Barbara, including one in which Barbara said, I got rid of it all. I got rid of the junk. After three hours of deliberating, the jury found Marvin Buddy Potter Jr. guilty of two counts of murder in the first degree. Buddy remained stoic as the verdict was read, just as he had been throughout the trial. As Tennessee law requires a murder one conviction to automatically carry one life sentence per count, Buddy would have to serve two life sentences. Afterwards, the prosecution queried the jurors about what they thought of the testimony,
巴迪卡车里发现的散装、未击发的子弹与犯罪现场发现的子弹相吻合。陪审团还听取了巴迪和芭芭拉之间录下的通话录音，其中包括芭芭拉说的一句话：“我都处理掉了。我把那些垃圾都扔了。”经过三个小时的审议，陪审团裁定小马文·巴迪·波特两项一级谋杀罪名成立。宣读判决时，巴迪表现得无动于衷，正如他在整个审判过程中一样。由于田纳西州法律规定一级谋杀罪定罪后每项指控自动判处终身监禁，巴迪将不得不服刑两项终身监禁。随后，检方询问陪审员他们对证词的看法，
and importantly, how they felt about the culpability of Barbara and Janelle Potter. The feedback they got was that the women were every bit as guilty as Buddy, even if they didn't pull the trigger. Janelle, Jamie and Barbara were set to face trial on two counts of first degree murder and conspiracy to commit first degree murder. Barbara also faced a charge of tampering with evidence, thanks to her ill-fated attempt to shred the emails and photos. The three would be tried together. Then in early 2015, Assistant District Attorney Dennis Brooks received a call from Jamie's attorney. Jamie was prepared to cooperate with the state if it meant having a shot at freedom. He provided a full confession, detailing from the moment Buddy asked
更重要的是，他们如何看待芭芭拉和珍妮尔·波特的罪责。他们得到的反馈是，这两名女性与巴迪同样罪责难逃，哪怕她们没有扣动扳机。珍妮尔、杰米和芭芭拉将面临两项一级谋杀罪和共谋一级谋杀罪的审判。芭芭拉还面临一项篡改证据的指控，原因在于她试图粉碎电子邮件和照片的倒霉尝试。这三人将同时受审。随后在2015年初，助理地区检察官丹尼斯·布鲁克斯接到了杰米律师的电话。杰米准备与州方合作，只要这意味着能有一线获得自由的机会。他提供了全面的供词，详细讲述了从巴迪请求
him to do him a favor, to when Jamie was dropped off home after Buddy executed Bill Payne and Billie Jean Hayworth. In return for agreeing to testify against the Potter women, Jamie was tried separately with the lesser charge of facilitation of first degree murder. He pleaded guilty and was sentenced to 25 years, with the possibility of applying for parole in seven and a half years. As he had already served over half of that, his first parole hearing occurred in November 2015. The victims' families all opposed parole, with Assistant District Attorney Dennis Brooks saying, it would be a slap in the face of justice for Jamie Curd to be released so early in his sentence. Parole was denied, with Jamie eligible to try again at a later date.
他帮个忙的时刻，一直到巴迪处决了比尔·佩恩和比利·珍·海沃斯后杰米被送到家。作为同意出庭指控波特女性的交换条件，杰米被单独审判，罪名较轻，即协助一级谋杀。他认罪并被判处25年监禁，并有权在七年半后申请假释。由于他已经服刑超过了一半，他的第一次假释听证会发生在2015年11月。受害者家属全都反对假释，助理地区检察官丹尼斯·布鲁克斯说：“如果杰米·柯德在服刑这么早的时候就被释放，这将是对正义的一记耳光。”假释被驳回，杰米有资格在晚些时候再次尝试。
In May 2015, the Potter women went to trial. Grayhead Barbara entered court each day in a wheelchair while her daughter dressed demurely. Assistant District Attorney Dennis Brooks opened with the statement, this is going to be the stupidest thing you've ever heard. This is going to be the craziest thing you've ever heard. There is nothing in your lives or background that has prepared you to understand the Potter family. You have never seen anybody like them. Even with the Jamie now the prosecution's star witness, there was no smoking gun. In the pages upon pages of online correspondence, neither Barbara nor Janelle outright demanded that Buddy and Jamie go out and kill. The defense argued that Jamie Curd, who had the
2015年5月，波特家的女性迎来了审判。满头白发的芭芭拉每天坐着轮椅进入法庭，而她的女儿则穿着端庄。助理地区检察官丹尼斯·布鲁克斯在开场陈词中说道：“这将是你们听过的最愚蠢的事情。这将是你们听过的最疯狂的事情。你们生活或背景中的任何经历都没有让你们做好准备去理解波特家族。你们从未见过这样的人。”尽管杰米现在是检方的首席证人，但并没有确凿的“冒烟的枪”（直接证据）。在成页成页的网络通信中，芭芭拉或珍妮尔都没有直截了当地要求巴迪和杰米出去杀人。辩方辩称，杰米·柯德拥有
know-how and access to the Potter's computer, was behind the murders and online personas. The defense maintained that Jamie was upset because he'd lost his drinking buddy when Bill Payne became involved with Billie Jean Hayworth and that he wanted Janelle's parents out of the way so he could have Janelle to himself. The defense pointed out that Jamie had every opportunity to stop the murders, but he didn't. Janelle's attorney called the state's argument smoke and mirrors and told the jury, the state will have you believe that Janelle Potter coerced Jamie Curd, a man 8 to 10 years older than her, to complete these acts. Some beat when Janelle Potter operated on the level of an 8 or 9 year old. He also cautioned the jury to remember that it's not
技术和接触波特家电脑的权限，才是谋杀案和网络假身份的幕后黑手。辩方坚称，杰米很不高兴，因为当比尔·佩恩与比利·珍·海沃斯好上时，他失去了酒友，他想把珍妮尔的父母弄走，这样他就可以独占珍妮尔了。辩方指出，杰米有大把的机会阻止谋杀，但他没有。珍妮尔的律师称州方的论点是“烟幕弹”，并对陪审团说：“州方会让你相信珍妮尔·波特胁迫了比她大8到10岁的杰米·柯德去完成这些行为。”同时暗示珍妮尔·波特的智力水平只相当于一个8、9岁的孩子。他还提醒陪审团记住，在网上
illegal to spew hate and vitriol over the internet in an apparent admission that his client had done just that. The witness who offered the most insight into Janelle Potter was her estranged older sister Christie. Christie's childhood was relatively normal, but Janelle, with all her difficulties, received the bulk of their parents' attention. Christie noted that her parents coddled her little sister, always taking care of any issues she faced, including those that were of her own making. Janelle sought attention by making false health claims such as that she had cancer. At other times, she would collapse dramatically in the hallways, waiting for people to notice and make a fuss over her. Janelle's inability to reason meant that she was unable to understand
宣泄仇恨和刻薄言论并不违法，这显然是在变相承认他的当事人确实做过这样的事。对珍妮尔·波特提供最多洞察力的证人是她疏远的大姐克里斯蒂。克里斯蒂的童年相对正常，但珍妮尔伴随着她所有的困难，得到了父母绝大部分的关注。克里斯蒂指出，她的父母娇惯她的小妹妹，总是照顾她面临的任何问题，包括那些她自己惹出来的麻烦。珍妮尔通过做出虚假的健康声称来博取关注，例如宣称自己得了癌症。有时，她会在走廊里戏剧性地晕倒，等着别人注意到她并为她大惊小怪。珍妮尔缺乏推理能力，这意味着她无法理解
when other kids were joking. She took things too seriously and in ways the other party did not intend. As a result, Janelle had trouble making friends and would often get into disagreements and conflicts. Her parents would step in and either smooth things over or threaten the other party until they backed down. In middle school, a dispute between Janelle and another girl went all the way to court. Janelle claimed the girl had punched her because Janelle was too pretty. Buddy and Barbara drummed into Janelle how different she was and gushed that this made her special and better than other kids. Over time, Christie came to believe that her little sister's disabilities were quote, not as bad as everybody else said they were. She felt pushed to the
当别的孩子在开玩笑时，她却把事情看得太认真，理解的方式也与对方的本意相去甚远。因此，珍妮尔很难交到朋友，还经常陷入争执和冲突中。她的父母会介入其中，要么大事化小，要么威胁对方直到对方退缩。在初中时，珍妮尔和另一个女孩的矛盾甚至闹到了法庭。珍妮尔声称那个女孩打了她，因为珍妮尔长得太漂亮了。巴迪和芭芭拉不断向珍妮尔灌输她有多么与众不同，并大加赞赏，认为这让她很特别，比别的孩子更优秀。随着时间的推移，克里斯蒂开始相信，她小妹的残疾其实并没有其他人说的那么严重。她觉得自己被挤到了
sidelines as her parents were consumed with loving and protecting their favorite daughter, Janelle. She mostly attributed her troubled childhood and strained familial relationships with her mother. Christie eventually moved out and severed ties with her family. She felt that Janelle manipulated and deceived other people for her own ends, especially their parents. A psychologist told the jury, the allegation that Janelle is in some way a mastermind or a manipulator or a planner I think really flies in the face of the facts, which go back and say that she is functioning basically as a fourth grader. When the prosecution then asked, can a nine-year-old be manipulative,
边缘，因为她的父母把所有的心思都放在了关爱和保护他们最喜欢的女儿珍妮尔身上。她把坎坷的童年和紧张的家庭关系大多归咎于她的母亲。克里斯蒂最终搬了出去，并断绝了与家人的联系。她觉得珍妮尔为了达到自己的目的操纵和欺骗了其他人，尤其是他们的父母。一位心理学家在法庭上对陪审团说，关于珍妮尔在某种程度上是一个策划者、操纵者或谋划者的指控，我认为这完全违背了事实，事实证明她的智力水平基本上只相当于四年级学生。当控方随后发问，九岁的孩子难道就不会操控别人吗，
the psychologist responded, nine-year-olds manipulate their parents all the time. Barbara and Janelle Potter were found to guilty on all charges. Both women were sentenced to two life sentences, one for each count of first-degree murder. Unlike Buddy, who had remained impassive when his sentence was read out, Barbara and Janelle erupted into dramatic tears. Barbara, at 64, would die in prison. Janelle, at 35, would be in her 80s before being eligible for parole. The relatives of Bill and Billie Jean were even more emotional this time than they were when Buddy had been convicted. Everyone in town knew what a menace Janelle was and how she had been the cause of so much drama, hatred and angst over the years.
这位心理学家回答说，九岁的孩子无时无刻不在操控他们的父母。芭芭拉和珍妮尔·波特被裁定所有罪名成立。两名女性都被判处两项终身监禁，每项一级谋杀罪名各判一项。与宣读判决时一直面无表情的巴迪不同，芭芭拉和珍妮尔情绪失控，放声大哭。64岁的芭芭拉将在狱中度过余生。35岁的珍妮尔则要到80多岁才有资格获得假释。比尔和比利·让的亲属这次的情绪比巴迪被定罪时更加激动。镇上的所有人都知道珍妮尔是个多大的祸害，多年来她是如何引发了如此多的戏剧性事件、仇恨和焦虑的。
Few had been confident that she would be made to pay for her crimes, let alone a murder conviction. Their relief was overwhelming. Bill Payne's mother told the press, We're still hurting, we'll always be hurting. You know, Bill couldn't call me on Mother's Day. She also had a parting shot for Barbara Potter, referencing one of the emails that had been read out in court, she said, Barbara, you wanted to know if you'd go to hell? Yeah, you're going to hell. And if I have to forgive any of you to stay out of hell, I'll see you there. Shortly after the trials, television program 2020 did a show about the case called Unfriended. Both Barbara and Janelle, who were serving their sentences in the same prison,
很少有人有信心她能为自己的罪行付出代价，更不用说谋杀罪名成立了。他们的如释重负是压倒性的。比尔·佩恩的母亲对记者说，我们仍然在痛苦，我们永远都会痛苦。你知道，比尔在母亲节那天没法给我打电话。她还对芭芭拉·波特进行了最后的回击，她提到了法庭上宣读过的一封电子邮件，她说，芭芭拉，你想知道你会不会下地狱吗？是的，你要下地狱了。如果为了远离地狱我必须原谅你们中的任何人，那我在地狱见你。审判结束后不久，电视节目《2020》制作了一期关于此案的节目，名为《取消好友》。芭芭拉和珍妮尔被关押在同一所监狱服刑，
were interviewed on camera. They continued to deny any involvement in the murders. Barbara said Jamie Curd had authored all the dimming emails using her name. I'm not that kind of person, she insisted. I'm not evil. She believed that she would go to heaven with a clean conscience. Janelle used a tactic that had always served her well with her parents. When the interviewer confronted her with evidence that she was Chris, she sobbed loudly and cried, no, no, no, until her lawyer ended the interview. Agent Scott Lott was also interviewed and was at a pains to distance the case from
两人都在镜头前接受了采访。她们继续否认参与了谋杀。芭芭拉说杰米·柯德用她的名字撰写了所有威胁邮件。她坚称，我不是那种人。我并不邪恶。她相信自己能带着清白的良心上天堂。珍妮尔则使出了对付父母一向屡试不爽的伎俩。当采访者拿着她是克里斯的证据质问她时，她放声痛哭，大喊不，不，不，直到她的律师终止了采访。探员斯科特·洛特也接受了采访，他极力撇清此案与
the narrative that it was all about social media. He believed a much more common motive was the true answer. Janelle Potter had an unrequited crush on Bill Payne and was furious that it hadn't been reciprocated. He said, It wasn't befriending on Facebook. It was a jealousy issue and someone with too much time on her hands. The sentiment in Mountain City is that the Potter women had manipulated the impressionable desperate and lonely Jamie Curd to do something he would never normally do. Before meeting the Potters, Jamie had no prior history of violence and no criminal history. In his book on the case Too Pretty to Live, Assistant District Attorney Dennis Brooks
社交媒体并无直接关系的说法。他相信一个更常见的动机才是真正的答案。珍妮尔·波特对比尔·佩恩怀有单相思，并对对方没有回报她的感情感到愤怒。他说，这不是在脸书上交友。这是一个嫉妒问题，而且是一个游手好闲的人干的事。山城当地的舆论普遍认为，波特母女操纵了那个易受影响、绝望且孤独的杰米·柯德，让他去做出他平时绝不会做的事。在遇到波特一家之前，杰米没有任何暴力史，也没有犯罪记录。助理地方检察官丹尼斯·布鲁克斯在他撰写的关于此案的书《太漂亮而不能死》中
expressed some sympathy for the man who had become the pawn of a jealous, controlling, and vindictive girl and her overprotective parents. He wrote, Had the Potters not come into Jamie's life, he would have gone to his grave without a single incident as a violent criminal. I truly believed that. Online, Janelle Potter often wrote about her love for her parents. She put them down as her heroes, adding, I have the best mama and daddy in the world. They have really been there for me and they are great people. I'm so lucky I am blessed with them. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对这个男人表达了一些同情，他成了一个充满嫉妒、控制欲强且心胸狭窄的女孩以及她那过度保护的父母手中的一颗棋子。他写道，如果波特一家没有闯入杰米的生活，他本可以带着没有一起暴力犯罪记录的人生走到生命的尽头。我深信这一点。在网络上，珍妮尔·波特经常表达她对父母的爱。她把他们奉为自己的英雄，并补充说，我有世界上最好的妈妈和爸爸。他们真的对我很支持，而且他们都是伟大的人。我很幸运，能有他们陪伴。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。